Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittloff und ich begrüße alle zur 109.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und ja, kosmische Angelegenheiten, darum geht's heute glaube ich mal wieder.
Aber es geht auch um die Raumfahrt.
Ich habe mal wieder eine Reise angetreten. Der Weg hat mich nach Ulm geführt
zu einem relativ neuen Institut des DLR und begrüße erst mal meine Gesprächspartnerin
heute, nämlich Frau Lisa Wörner.
Hallo, sehr schön, dass ich da sein darf.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Frau Wörner, Sie sind die Leiterin oder
kommissarische Leiterin, wenn ich es richtig notiert habe, dieses Instituts.
Macht das einen Unterschied?
Absolut, das macht absoluten Unterschied. Mein Nachfolger ist bereits bestimmt
und ich werde den Posten dann abgeben. Ich verwalte im Moment das Institut bis er kommt.
Okay, also Sie managen sozusagen die Aufbaufase, die allererste.
Genau so.
Weil das ganze ist ja erst vor kurzem gegründet worden.
Wir sind 2019 gegründet worden. Der Gründungsdirektor war noch jemand anders.
Ich durfte das dann von ihm übernehmen, eben bis mein Nachfolger kommt.
Und damit sind wir jetzt erst vier Jahre alt oder werden dieses Jahr erst vier Jahre alt.
Was für so ein DLR-Institut ja geradezu Babyzustand ist.
Total. Mit uns zusammen wurden noch sechs andere Institute gegründet.
Drei von diesen sechs Instituten im Bereich der Quantentechnologie, eines davon wir.
Und wir sind ganz ganz jung im DLR und versuchen uns da jetzt gerade mit den
anderen Partnern zusammenzufinden und Verbindungen zu knüpfen und unsere Forschung zu betreiben.
Genau, Institut für Quantentechnologie, müssen wir auch mal ausgesprochen haben,
darum geht es hier. Also hier werden die Quanten durch die Gegend geworfen und beobachtet.
Da werden wir jetzt gleich ausführlich drüber reden, aber vielleicht würde mich
auch mal interessieren, was macht denn das anders? Also ich meine,
wenn man jetzt so ein etabliertes Institut reinkommt, da ist dann schon alles
eingeruckelt, das haben wir schon immer so gemacht und so.
Das ist ja dann im Prinzip Aufgabe und Freiheit in einem, oder?
Ist eine total spannende Aufgabe, so ein Institut neu aufzubauen und auch total
spannend die Strategie für so ein Institut zu gestalten und auch die Zukunft
zu entwickeln. Wo wollen wir hin? Das sind ja jetzt alles so Grundpfeiler,
die jetzt gelegt werden.
Ob wir Dinge grundlegend anders machen als andere Institute,
weiß ich nicht, aber unsere Aufgabe ist natürlich eine andere.
Bei uns geht es jetzt wirklich darum, die Phänomene, die wir aus der Quantenphysik kennen,
die Quantenphysik, die wirklich auch schon jahrelang, fast ein Jahrhundert inzwischen
untersucht wird und erforscht wird,
jetzt diese Phänomene, die wir kennen, auch in die Anwendung zu bringen,
daraus eben eine Quantentechnologie zu machen und nicht mehr nur Quantenphysik.
Superspannende Aufgabe.
Wenn ich's richtig sehe, ist das Institut so ein bisschen...
Auf der einen Seite schon auch ein wenig in der Grundlagenforschung verwurzelt,
versucht aber sehr viel mehr so einen Brückenschlag zu machen in die konkrete Anwendung.
So richtig viel Grundlagenforschung machen wir nicht. Wir untersuchen nicht
mehr warum irgendwie ein Phänomen wie auftritt.
Unser Ansatz ist tatsächlich zu verstehen, wie wir diese Phänomene verwenden
können. Dafür müssen wir sie untersuchen, dafür müssen wir sie verstehen,
dafür müssen wir sie handhaben können.
Kann man durchaus der Grundlagenforschung zuwächen, ist aber für mich auch immer
schon ein angewendeter Ansatz.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie untersuche, wie Beschleunigungen das System
beeinflussen, dann untersuche ich das natürlich aber immer mit dem Ziel hintendran,
eine Technologie zu entwickeln, ein System zu entwickeln.
Was bei uns noch ganz speziell ist, ist, dass wir auch eine dezidierte Theorieabteilung
haben, die dafür da sind,
Neue, frische Ideen in das Institut zu bringen und auch neue Ideen aus der Forschung
heraus für uns relevant zu machen,
sodass wir da auch immer wieder gucken können, welche neuen Phänomene in der
Quantentechnologie oder Quantenmechanik wurden entdeckt, sind für uns vielleicht
relevant oder wo haben wir noch nicht genügend in die Tiefe geschaut,
um Dinge auch so umsetzen zu können, wie sie sinnvoll sind.
Wie hoch ist da so die Schlagzahl aus dieser Grundlagenforschung?
Wie viel muss man da so konsumieren pro Jahr?
Also wir lesen natürlich ganz viel, wir fahren ganz viel auf Konferenzen.
Ziel von uns ist es mindestens, also wir sind im Moment rund 50 Mitarbeiter,
dass wir mindestens 20 internationale Vorträge auch haben.
Sodass wir wirklich auch mit der Community kommunizieren wollen,
mit der Community gemeinsam mitarbeiten wollen im Moment.
Aktuell fokussieren wir uns noch auf die Technologien.
Vorträge die man hält oder die hier gehalten werden?
Dabei geht es vor allen Dingen um Vorträge, die wir halten, bei denen wir natürlich
auch Sichtbarkeit schaffen, aber was auch heißt, dass wir rausgehen,
dass wir uns auf Konferenzen zeigen.
Die Zahl ist sicherlich zu niedrig, ich glaube wir machen viel viel mehr,
das ist aber so unsere Zielvorgabe und gleichzeitig haben wir im Moment auch
einen wöchentlichen oder zwei wöchentlichen Termin,
wo wir auch hier Vorträge haben, wo wir auch externe Kollegen einladen,
auch das für uns ein ganz wichtiges Thema natürlich Leute reinzuholen.
Also Institut für Quantentechnologie und das heißt halt hier geht es wirklich
um die Anwendung und nicht nur um die Forschung, aber man ist halt natürlich
mit dieser Forschung auch verbunden.
Bevor wir dann vielleicht noch mehr auf die Struktur kommen und vielleicht auch
nochmal so ein bisschen die Grundlagen all dessen beleuchten,
um das weitere verstehen zu können, würde mich natürlich nochmal interessieren,
Was sie eigentlich so hierher geführt hat. Wann hat sie denn das Thema Wissenschaft erwischt?
Mein Leben ist eines in Umwegen. Ich hab tatsächlich Physik studiert,
ich hatte auch in der Schule schon eine starke Affinität zur Physik,
sodass das bei mir auch geblieben ist und auch die Wissenschaft mich immer schon fasziniert hat.
Sicherlich auch ein bisschen aus dem familiären Umfeld, wo das auch immer ein starkes Thema war.
Und auch die Raumfahrt tatsächlich eine starke Faszination war,
die mich von Kindestagen an begleitet.
Und dann habe ich aber in meinem Studium zunächst mal an Hochenergiephysik gedacht,
habe mich also erstmal informiert über oder erstmal geforscht im Bereich von
Hochenergiephysik, Teilchenphysik.
Ich war damals vor allen Dingen an einem Experiment, was am FAIR in Darmstadt
stattfindet, aber das bekanntere Experiment ist jetzt FAIR, die Facility for
Anti-Protein and Iron Research.
Die bekanntere Einrichtung dazu ist das CERN. Jetzt habe ich sehr sehr lange
geredet über etwas, was ich nur ein Jahr getan habe.
War wohl aufregend. War total spannende Zeit. Diese großen Experimente.
Ich durfte in der Zeit auch ans CERN fahren und konnte den Large Hadron Collider,
der damals gebaut wurde, Ja so alt bin ich schon.
Tatsächlich auch noch von innen anschauen. Also ich konnte die großen Experimente
von innen anschauen. Alice hat mich damals unglaublich beeindruckt.
Also wirklich ganz tolle Experimente, ganz spannende Physik.
Und bin dann von dort aus in die Plasmaphysik gegangen.
Das Max-Planck-Institut für Extraterrestrik und hab dort meinen Doktor gemacht.
Mit einer Phase in Frankreich in der Zeit.
Wo ist das? In München?
Ich habe auch in München studiert und bin dann nach dem Abschluss meines Doktorats
oder während meines Doktorats, habe ich angefangen viele Audiobücher zu hören
und habe dann tatsächlich von Stephen Hawking den großen Entwurf gehört.
Und in diesem Buch spricht er über ein Experiment mit dem Doppelspalt,
wo Menschen es geschafft haben, Fullerene, das sind Moleküle aus 60 Kohlenstoffatomen,
die bauen sich zusammen wie so ein Fußball, sehen die am Ende aus.
Benannt nach Buckminster Fuller.
Genau, Fullerene, Buckyballs, wie auch immer man sie nennen möchte,
dass die damit Interferenzexperimente gemacht haben.
Und Interferenzexperimente habe ich verstanden aus der Universität,
war aber für mich immer so ein Welleteilchen, das ist alles super klein und
was Lichter macht und so, Papier ist total geduldig, da kann man ganz viel drüber
reden, alles easy und hab dieses Experiment gehört und hab gedacht,
prove it to me and I still won't believe it.
Douglas Adams Zitat an dieser Stelle, aber ja. und bin dann...
Auf die Suche gegangen und wurde dann eingeladen, weil ich war irgendwie klar,
dass ich nicht in dieser Gruppe würde bleiben wollen und ich wollte mich auch
weiterentwickeln nach dem Doktor, aber es war nicht so genau klar,
wo ich, wo die Reise hingehen würde und wurde dann eingeladen auf eine sehr
spannende Konferenz mit ganz, ganz vielen verschiedenen Themen.
Und dort stellte Markus Arndt dann genau dieses Experiment vor und ich saß im
Auditorium und hab gedacht, niemals, das kann doch nicht funktionieren,
das geht nicht, mein Gehirn schafft es nicht, das zu verstehen.
War dann, im Englischen würde man sagen lucky enough, im Deutschen.
Ich hatte dann das Glück, tatsächlich in dieser Forschungsgruppe dann forschen
zu dürfen bei Markus Arndt, der mich dann eingeladen hat und ich war dann dort
zwei Jahre und habe mit ihm dort in Wien hochmassige Interferenz gemacht.
Also wirklich die Frage, wo hört die Quantenmechanik auf, wo ist die Validität
der Quantenmechanik am Ende.
Ja und ab da hat es mich dann gepackt und ich bin dann von dort nach Bremen
gegangen, wo wir dann Frequenzreferenzen angeschaut haben und uns dann angefangen
haben auf den Wellenteilchendualismus mit Atomen zu fokussieren.
Das war für mich dann sehr einfach zu schlucken, nachdem ich geschluckt hatte, dass man so 20.000.
Atomare Masseneinheitenteilchen interferieren kann, also wirklich,
wirklich große Teilchen interferieren kann, waren dann Atome für mich nicht mehr so das Thema.
Was dann dazu geführt hat, dass ich Projektleitung wurde im Projekt Bekal,
da werden wir sicherlich gleich nochmal drüber sprechen, ins Detail ein bisschen gehen.
Das hat mich am Ende des Tages dann an dieses neu gegründete Institut hier in
Ulm geführt. Da ich in München studiert habe, war das für mich auch dann örtlich
ein interessantes Thema.
Dann hat sich die Chance ergeben eben hier auch die Leitung Kommissarisch zu
übernehmen und jetzt sitzen wir hier. Wie gesagt Umwege, sehr sehr lange gesprochen.
Ja, aber immer interessant. So,
jetzt merkt man schon, das ist ein heikles Thema hier mit der ganzen Quantenmechanik,
das ist so eine Technologie, wir haben es ja schon erwähnt,
gibt es seit 100 Jahren, aber ich hab so den Eindruck,
das ist so, Also nicht, dass jetzt komplexe physikalische Vorgänge generell
in einer breiten Öffentlichkeit immer so jederzeit abgerufen werden können.
Von vielen hat man was gehört, von manchen haben viele auch eine Vorstellung,
aber mit der Vorstellungskraft im Quantenbereich setzt es ja auch bei den Physikern
dann sicherlich hier und da auch mal aus.
Weil es ja einfach kurz gesagt und ich formuliere das jetzt einfach mal so mit
einer einfachen Sichtweise,
der Blick in das kleinste hat zutage gebracht, dass da auf einmal die Gesetze,
die man im größten beobachtet, nicht so ohne weiteres anzuwenden sind.
Und ja, hat mit der Quantenmechanik sozusagen nochmal so ein komplettes Genre
innerhalb der Physik geschaffen, wo sich ja auch lange gestritten wurde,
ob denn das denn alles so sein kann.
Das ist richtig. Ganz wichtig an der Stelle, nicht alles was Quantenmechanik ist, ist klein.
Und auch der Quantensprung, der so viel benutzt wird, der ist weder klein noch
groß. Der Quantensprung beschreibt die kleinste Einheit, die man sich bewegen
kann. Deswegen ist das für mich immer so ein Pet und Peeve, wenn Menschen das benutzen.
Ein lustiges Statement. Jetzt haben wir ja einen Quantenfonds gemacht.
Alles klar, es hat richtig vorangekommen.
Wo wir jetzt schon drüber sprechen, gebe ich Ihnen kurz ein Beispiel,
vielleicht hilft das so ein bisschen zu verstehen, warum mich das so zum Lachen bringt.
Geld ist typischerweise gequantet. Ich kann Ihnen einen Cent geben,
ich kann Ihnen zwei Cent geben, ich tue mich sehr schwer Ihnen einen halben
Cent zu geben. Das heißt, es gibt hier eine kleinste Einheit,
die ich Ihnen geben kann, nämlich den einen Cent. Geld ist deswegen gequantet.
Das ist im Prinzip Digitalisierung, könnte man es auch nennen.
Also man schafft halt einfach Schrittweiten, die klar abzählbar sind und das
ist die Quantifizierung.
Wenn sie das so möchten, ja da muss ich jetzt noch drüber nachdenken,
ob ich dem so mitgehe, aber das können wir mal so stehen lassen.
Aber prinzipiell geht es darum.
Ja bei Computern gibt es ja auch kein halbes Bit und das ist ja sozusagen die
Schrittweite, auf die man sich geeinigt hat.
Genau, ein anderes schönes Beispiel sind Parkplätze. Parkplätze sind an sich
auch gequantelt, nur dass wir es dauernd verletzen. Aber prinzipiell.
Also halb befüllte Parkplätze habe ich schon gesehen.
Ja, ich auch. Prinzipiell werden die aber auch gequantelt. Genau,
jetzt habe ich vergessen. Wo wollte ich hin?
Zur Quantenmechanik. Und warum, ja, was das Wesen dieses Forschungsbereiches
ist und was müssen wir verstehen, um das zu verstehen, was dieses Institut macht?
Also ganz ganz wichtig über Quantenmechanik, wenn man über Quantenmechanik spricht,
ist, dass wir uns von der Vorstellung, wie die Welt für uns sich so darstellt,
ein bisschen verabschieden müssen.
Wir sitzen jetzt hier an einem Tisch, das heißt sie sagen, auch wenn sie aus
dem Raum rausgehen, der Tisch ist hier.
Und ich sage ihnen, wenn ich aus dem Raum rausgehe, dass es nur eine gewisse
Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt, dass dieser Tisch hier ist.
Die ist wahrscheinlich fast eins, aber sie ist eben halt nicht eins.
Und das ist so der ganz große Unterschied zwischen der Beschreibung der Welt
in der Quantenmechanik oder der Beschreibung der Welt in zum Beispiel Newtonischer Mechanik.
Das ist so das, was wirklich unten drunter liegt, dass wir nichts beschreiben
als das ist da oder das ist nicht da,
sondern es wird allem eine sogenannte Wellenfunktion zugewiesen,
die dann beschreibt, welche Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Objekt hat, irgendwo zu sein.
Welche Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Elektron hat, in einer bestimmten Entfernung zum Kern zu sein.
Wenn wir bei dem Beispiel bleiben, ist es die Quantenmechanik,
die dann von dem Borsch-Naturmodell mit den Kreisen weggeht hin zu diesen Orbitalen.
Die Orbitale beschreiben eine Aufenthaltswahrscheinlichkeit der Elektronen um den Kern herum.
Nur bis zu einer gewissen Größe. Es gibt wieder eine von Null verschiedene Wahrscheinlichkeit
außerhalb, aber prinzipiell ist das das, was die Quantenmechanik tut.
Du die Vorstellung des Atoms umgeben von so einer Elektronenwolke,
was halt nach wie vor eine definierte Anzahl von Elektronen hat,
aber eben unbestimmbar wo sich etwas befindet, solange bis man es dann misst.
Genau, genau. Und das ist tatsächlich auch, um wieder zurückzukommen,
genauso funktioniert auch dieses Experiment mit den Fullerenen.
Die Fullerene verhalten sich wie Wellen. Interferenz ist ein ganz typisches Wellenexperiment.
Also wir reden ja von einem Molekül jetzt hier, gell?
Wir reden von einem Molekül, von einem großen Molekül. Einem Molekül,
was man mit einem Elektronenmikroskop tatsächlich sehen kann.
Also noch nicht sichtbar mit dem reinen Auge, aber was tatsächlich sichtbar
gemacht werden kann. Also es ist wirklich nicht mehr klein.
Und Interferenz ist ein typisches Wellenphänomen, kann ich nur im Wellenbild
erklären, kann ich nicht erklären, wenn ich im Teilchenbild bleibe.
Um das Wellenbild kurz zu verstehen und was Interferenz ist,
wenn Sie an einem schönen,
ruhigen See stehen, so einem ganz spiegelglatten See,
wo sich wirklich auch die Berge auf der anderen Seite drin spiegeln und es ist
wirklich ganz ruhig und Sie nehmen zwei Steine und werfen sie in das Wasser,
Dann bilden sich so konzentrische Wellen um diese Steine, da wo die Steine ins
Wasser eingedrungen sind.
Da wo die Wellenberge sich treffen, wird es dann doppelt so hoch,
da wo die Wellen Täler sich treffen, wird es doppelt so niedrig.
Und sie werden wie so ein Karomuster beobachten im Wasser, eben dieses sogenannte Interferenzmuster.
Und das lässt sich nur erklären durch die Überlagerung von Wellen mit einer
sogenannten konstruktiver Interferenz, also da wo sich Wellen verstärken,
und destruktiver Interferenz, da wo sie sich auslöschen. und damit bekommt man
dieses Karo-Muster im Wasser.
Und das funktioniert hier jetzt genauso nur, dass die Fullerene nicht die Steine
sind, die wir ins Wasser geworfen haben.
Das wäre ja super einfach zu verstehen, sondern die Fullerene sind die Wellen,
die sich vorwärts bewegen.
Das heißt, statt die Fullerene wie Objekte zu beschreiben, beschreiben wir die
Fullerene jetzt als sich vorwärts propagierende Welle, die und jetzt kommt der
ganz schlimme Teil, jedes von diesen Fullerenen geht gleichzeitig durch beide Spalten durch.
Statt dass das Folleren, das Teilchen was wir kennen, durch einen Spalt durchgeht,
interferiert hintendran mit sich selber und produziert das Interferenzmuster.
Das ist ganz schön viel Information auf einmal gewesen.
Genau, also ein Folleren muss man sich ja vorstellen wie ein Fußball.
Also der klassische Fußball, der seit ein paar Jahrzehnten ist, also der sich aus so.
Einem Hexagon und Pentagons zusammensetzt, das ist ja im Prinzip die Molekülstruktur
von der wir hier sprechen.
Schwierig. Also zunächst mal das Interferenzmuster. Der Punkt von diesem Doppelspaltexperiment
ist, dass man eben hinten nicht einfach das Schattenbild des Doppelspaltes findet,
sondern eben ein Interferenzmuster.
Wenn ich ein Interferenzmuster finde, Interferenz kann ich nur mit Welleneigenschaften
erklären. Das heißt, da muss ich komplett raus aus dem Partikelbild.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben sie das auch mal in der Schule gesehen mit
Lasern oder manche, wir haben das mit Wasserwellen gesehen, diese Beugungsphänomene
und so was, Interferenzphänomene, das ist im Prinzip alles das gleiche.
Das heißt, das funktioniert auch mit den Fußballen, das funktioniert auch mit
den Pistolenkugeln, das funktioniert mit allen Arten von Teilchen,
wir können es im Moment noch nicht mit der Größe, wir haben es mit der Größe
noch nicht gezeigt. Und auch Molekülen.
Wir sprechen jetzt wirklich bei diesem Fullerenbeispiel davon,
dass man jetzt quasi so ein Doppelspalt-Setup hat und da fliegen dann diese ganzen Moleküle durch.
Korrekt, korrekt. Und das Experiment, was Sie gerade angesprochen haben mit
den Elektronen, das ist rund aus den 60er-Jahren.
Das heißt, das ist auch so etwa 30 Jahre, 40 Jahre nach der Prostellation des
Welle-Teilchen-Dualismus.
Also es hat sehr, sehr lange gedauert, bis wir von dem Welle-Teilchen-Dualismus,
von der theoretischen Beschreibung hingekommen sind, dass wir tatsächlich auch
ein Experiment dafür hatten.
Fun Fact am Rande, das wissen Sie bestimmt auch, Einstein hat seinen Nobelpreis
nicht bekommen für die Relativitätstheorie, sondern tatsächlich für den sogenannten
photoelektrischen Effekt, der als erster den Welle-Teilchen-Dualismus gezeigt hat, nur andersrum.
Er hat gezeigt, dass sich Licht nicht nur wie eine Welle verhält,
sondern auch wie ein Teilchen.
Das ist dann der Ausgangspunkt auch durchaus der Quantenmechanik.
Und dieses Gleichzeitig beim Welle-Teilchen-Dualismus ist so eine Sache.
Prinzipiell ist da schon so eine Gleichzeitigkeit da, wie ich das aber lieber
formuliere, ist, dass ich jedes Teilchen auch wie eine Welle beschreiben kann
und eine Welle wie ein Teilchen.
Und jetzt muss ich das passende Bild wählen, was zu dem Phänomen passt, das ich sehe.
Das ist häufig ein Problem oder war auch lange für mich als Physiker ein Problem,
weil das kann doch nicht sein, dass ich irgendwie etwas wähle basierend auf dem, was ich messe.
Aber tatsächlich ist es eben genau so. Auch Sie machen das. Sie wählen hinterher
basierend auf Ihrem Messergebnis eine Erklärung für die Thematik,
die Sie gemessen haben. Wenn Sie jetzt morgen irgendwo hinkommen,
da ist ein Autounfall, dann haben Sie auch irgendwie eine Idee, was da passiert ist.
Und genau das gleiche machen wir hier auch. Nicht ganz so dramatisch.
Aber im Prinzip wählen wir hier auch dann ein Bild basierend auf dem,
was wir zeigen konnten. Und können zum Beispiel mit diesen Interferenzexperimenten
eben tatsächlich zeigen, dass Moleküle auch der Quantenmechanik unterliegen.
Was war jetzt bei den Follerenen so besonders, also was war dieser unglaubliche Aspekt?
Die sind einfach so groß. Die sind einfach riesig. Also bei Elektronen, die sehe ich nicht.
Da kann ich irgendwie noch akzeptieren, dass das da durchgeht.
Bei Atomen tue ich mich schon sehr, sehr schwer.
Das waren einfach die Fullerene, die ich dann damals als erstes gehört habe,
auch vor den Elektronen und vor den Atomen.
Und es war für mich sehr schwer vorstellbar, tatsächlich da hinzugehen und diesen
Auflösungsprozess sozusagen, das Aufgehen eines substanziellen Teilchens in
eine Welle und dann wirklich die Beschreibung in einer Welle.
Und inzwischen sind die bei Teilchen,
die haben rund 20.000 atomare Masseneinheiten, irgendwie 1.500 Atome.
Das sind richtig, richtig große Moleküle, die immer noch Welleneigenschaften
zeigen. Das ist im Moment der aktuelle Massenrekord, der in Wien gehalten wird.
Also auch wenn der Tisch so hart wirkt, wenn man draufhaut und man so eine Vorstellung
von der ganzen Welt hat, dass das irgendwie alles so massiv ist.
Man weiß ja im Prinzip, Masse und Energie ist sowieso das gleiche,
aber eigentlich muss man es noch ein bisschen weiter denken und wir leben eigentlich
in einem großen Wellensalat.
Wir leben eigentlich in einem großen Wellensalat und dass der Tisch so hart,
das liegt an der Elektrodynamik, da ist einfach elektromagnetische Abstoßung,
deswegen ist der Tisch so hart.
Physik zu studieren kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, es macht aber ganz viel mit
der Welt um einen herum und es ist nicht immer schön.
Genau, also in diesem Wellensalat forscht jetzt,
Entschuldigung, entwickelt dieses Institut Technologien, also auf Basis dessen
was sozusagen die Forschung bisher alles so ergeben hat, weil dort Potenzial gesehen wird.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf die Sachen kommen, die hier jetzt angedacht werden,
was so in der Zukunft kommen soll, was hat denn die Quantentechnologie jemals für uns getan?
Also was ist denn sozusagen schon bisher entstanden, was man jetzt in diesem
Feld zuordnen kann, wo man sagen kann, okay das ist jetzt sozusagen schon angewandte
Quantentechnologie gewesen?
Also natürlich ist es so, dass die Quantenmechanik auch unser Leben durchaus beherrscht.
Auch wenn wir die Technologie nicht entwickelt haben und wenn wir die Dinge nicht gemacht haben,
ist viel von den Prozessen, die so um uns herum passieren, von der Abstoßung
bis hin zu kosmischen Prozessen und sowas, Tunnelprozesse, alles quantenmechanische
Prozesse, die ganz wichtig sind.
Das ist nicht ihre Frage gewesen, aber trotzdem ist ganz viel von unserem Leben,
ganz viel von dem was passiert, tatsächlich viel besser mit Quantenmechanik
zu erklären als mit Newtonischer Mechanik.
Auch wenn wir immer das Problem haben, dass Newton für uns sehr sichtbar ist
und sehr greifbar, Dinge fallen runter, die Quantenmechanik eben halt so ein
bisschen schwierig ist für das Gehirn. Das ist okay, das hat was mit uns zu
tun, mehr als mit der Quantenmechanik.
Aber dafür gibt es ja Podcast.
Dafür geht es halt am Podcast, genau. Was hat die Quantenmechanik bisher für uns getan?
Es gibt ein ganz ganz wichtiges Beispiel, was gerne so ein bisschen vergessen wird.
Oder zwei sogar, zwei ganz wichtige Beispiele. Das eine sind Laser.
Laser ist auch nur ein Akronym, das ich jetzt bestimmt nicht sinnvoll zusammen bekomme.
Da ist irgendwie Light Amplification und das F ist Simulated Emission of Radiation.
Stimulierte Lichtverstärkung.
Genau, Stimulierte Lichtverstärkung. Was dabei ausgenutzt wird,
ist eben genau die Energielevels,
die sich in einem Atom befinden und auch die kann ich nur sinnvoll erklären,
wenn ich die Quantenmechanik zugrunde lege und die Aufenthaltswahrscheinlichkeiten
und damit die Energieniveaus berechnen kann und diese dann anregen kann,
sodass wir das möglichst gleichförmige
Licht am Ende des Tages rausbekommen, was dann ein Laser ist.
Das wird gerne mal bezeichnet als Quantentechnologie in der ersten Generation
und sowas, aber da fällt sicherlich der Laser schon drunter.
Das zweite Beispiel, das ich hier gerne bringen möchte, was auch nicht ganz
so bekannt ist, ist die globale Navigation.
Ich werde jetzt versuchen, ganz viel GNSS und Galileo zu sagen.
GNSS ist Global Next Generation Satellite System.
Globales Navigationssatellitensystem.
Genau.
Funktioniert auch auf Deutsch ist der Begriff. Prima.
Globales Navigationssatellitensystem und Galileo ist das europäische.
Das GNSS fasst Galileo, GLONASS und auch GPS zusammen.
Das umfasst so ein paar mehr.
Die funktionieren aber am Ende des Tages alle ganz ähnlich an Bord von diesen
Systemen sind Frequenzreferenzen.
Was ist eine Frequenzreferenz? Das ist im Prinzip ein Laser,
den man nochmal stabilisiert hat.
Aktuell ist es kein Laser, sondern es ist vor allen Dingen eine Radiofrequenz,
die nochmal stabilisiert wird, sodass die möglichst stabil läuft.
Also stabil im Sinne von konstante Frequenz.
Ganz konstante Frequenz, deswegen nennt man das eine Frequenzreferenz.
Die gibt ganz konstant immer wieder den gleichen Takt.
Ist übrigens das gleiche System was die PTB macht, die Physikalisch Technische
Bundesanstalt in Braunschweig, die die Funkuhren Signatur schickt.
Auch die haben eine Cesiumfrequenzreferenz, die gibt einfach ganz konstant basierend
auf dem Cesiummolekül hier, basierend auf anderen Systemen eine Frequenzreferenz.
Wenn Sie jetzt gerne wissen möchten, wo Sie sind, dann brauchen Sie vier Satelliten,
weil wir vier Unbekannte haben. Drei sind klar. Ich brauche irgendwie X,
Y und Z. Ich muss wissen, wo bin ich.
Wie machen die das? Der erste Satellit schickt ihnen eine Information, die sagt, ich bin jetzt.
Der sagt also ich bin 15 Uhr und schickt das zu Ihnen runter und das ist jetzt
sehr übertrieben, so lange dauert das nicht. Und Sie bekommen das unten und
stellen fest ich bin 15 Uhr eins, also ist der eine Sekunde von mir weg.
Das heißt ich muss diesen Abstand zu diesem Satelliten haben.
Das gibt uns irgendwie so einen Kreis auf der Erdoberfläche.
Jetzt sagt mir das der Zweite, dann habe ich zwei Kreise, die haben zwei Schnittpunkte.
Und ich bekomme einen Dritten und dann muss ich an einem Punkt sein.
Damit ich die Entfernung zu allen drei Satelliten richtig hinbekomme.
Ich habe gerade gesagt, wir brauchen vier.
Warum brauchen wir vier? Naja, der Punkt ist, dass keiner von uns eine hochgenaue
Frequenzreferenz in der Tasche hat. Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie auch wissen, wann bin ich.
Und damit habe ich vier unbekannte X, Y, Z und wann.
Und damit brauche ich einen vierten Satellit, der mir auch die Zeitsignale übermittelt
und damit mache ich die Navigation.
Das heißt, Frequenzreferenzen basierend auf kontenmechanischen Prinzipien ist
etwas, was wir im Moment auch schon benutzen.
Und warum ist das ein quantenmechanisches Prinzip? Weil es mit Wellen zu tun
hat und dann nennt man das dann schon so oder?
Weil schlicht und ergreifend das Atom, um das Atom sinnvoll zu beschreiben und
das Atom auch sinnvoll anregen zu können und lauter solche Sachen muss ich die
Quantenmechanik hernehmen.
Ich muss die Schrödinger Gleichung für das Elektronen im Feld des Atoms aufstellen,
dann bekomme ich diese Energieniveaus, die ich dann anregen kann und darauf
kann ich dann die Frequenzreferenz stabilisieren.
Damit sind Frequenzreferenzen tatsächlich wirklich quantenmechanische Systeme.
Das soll jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen helfen, um festzustellen,
dass Quantenmechanik nicht so abgehoben ist.
Das fühlt sich total normal an. Wir sind unheimlich gewohnt,
früher das GPS, das amerikanische System, das Global Positioning System,
das gibt es seit Jahrzehnten.
Wir sind unheimlich daran gewöhnt, dass das so funktioniert und es ist aber
trotzdem ein quantenmechanisches Prinzip, was unten drunter liegt,
was es uns ermöglicht, das zu nutzen.
Das ist das quantenmechanische Prinzip, was der Technologie,
die im Satelliten verbaut ist, sozusagen unterliegt. Also die Quantentechnologie
ist im Satellit und beim Empfänger ist es dann am Ende nur noch Mathematik.
Aber damit man sozusagen diese hochstabilen Frequenzen so überhaupt bekommen
kann, ist eben Quantentechnologie erforderlich.
Richtig.
Kurzer Spagat, mache ich immer ganz gerne, alte Sendung nochmal zu pluggen,
Raumzeit Nummer 8, lang ist es her,
2011, Felix Antreich eine sehr ausführliche Sendung zu Satelliten-Navigationssystemen gemacht,
der ist nämlich beim DLR für Galileo zuständig und genau, kann man mal reinhören,
ich glaube das stimmt alles noch, was da gesagt wurde.
Das war aber noch vor dem Launch sozusagen.
Also das ist quasi bei uns täglich der Fall. Gibt's noch irgendwas,
was man auf jeden Fall erwähnen muss?
Wie gesagt, die Zeit, die von der PTB gesetzt wird, wird nach dem gleichen Prinzip gesetzt.
Warum verspricht man sich jetzt so viel davon, dass man ein neues Institut gründen muss?
Also man kann ja auch sagen, okay, das mit den Soliden gelöstes Problem läuft.
Was braucht man denn jetzt noch?
Wo sieht man gerade die Verbesserungspotenziale existierender Technologie und
wo zeichnen sich neue Dinge ab, die es vielleicht so bisher noch gar nicht gibt?
Genau. Also ich glaube das Institut ist zur richtigen Zeitpunkt gegründet worden.
Schlicht und ergreifend deswegen, weil wir dafür da sind, die Sachen,
die Quantenphysik sind, jetzt zu transferieren in das, was Quantentechnologie ist.
Und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Übergang. Wir sind im Moment in einer Situation,
in der wir viel von der Quantenmechanik und auch von Prototypen so verstanden
haben, dass es ganz viele Ansätze gibt.
Und dass wir jetzt dafür da sind, um eben halt viele von diesen Ansätzen auch
Realität werden zu lassen.
Was häufig, natürlich funktioniert das auch in einem universitären Umfeld und
natürlich gibt es auch die Fraunhofer und es gibt auch die Max Plancks und keine
Ahnung dieser Welt und ganz viele Industriepartner, die auch schon großes Interesse daran haben.
Aber wir als DLR-Institut haben da eben auch nochmal einen sehr speziellen Auftrag
und können das auch sehr speziell nochmal angehen mit den entsprechenden Ressourcen,
die uns zur Verfügung stehen. Ich halte das für ganz wichtig.
Und ich halte das auch deswegen für wichtig, weil uns natürlich auch immer wieder gesagt wird,
dass Deutschland ein Hochtechnologie-Standort sein möchte und wir hier auch
eine ganz wichtige Technologie haben oder eine ganz wichtige,
ja sehr breite, das ist Quantentechnologien, wenn wir sofort hinkommen,
ist mehr so eine Überschnittstechnologie, die an ganz vielen Stellen eingreifen
kann, als dass das ist wie Fahrzeugbau.
Wir können im Fahrzeugbau helfen, aber wir sind nicht so eine alleine Säule wie der Fahrzeugbau,
sondern wir sind mehr so eine Überschnittsthematik, sodass ich das für ganz wichtig halte,
dass wir hier eben auch diese Ressource nutzen und weiter ausbauen und eben
dann auch mit der entsprechenden Industriepartner, mit entsprechenden Forschungspartnern
dafür sorgen, dass wir die Anwendung finden.
Da hilft es vielleicht auch nochmal kurz auf die Struktur des Instituts zu schauen,
weil hier gibt es ja verschiedene Forschungsabteilungen, die heißen dann glaube
ich auch so, aber auch nochmal Querschnittsabteilungen.
Erklären Sie doch nochmal kurz, was da so der Gedanke dahinter war,
warum es sinnvoll ist, das so aufzuspalten, wie es getan wurde und warum.
Bei uns beginnt eigentlich immer alles mit der Idee. Wir fangen vorne an mit
einer Idee, welches quantenmechanische Phänomen könnten wir dann nutzen,
um eine Applikation zu schaffen?
Welches Phänomen gibt es vielleicht, was spannend ist? Oder wo möchten wir nochmal
reinschauen? Und natürlich ist das auch so ein sich wiederholender Prozess.
Das heißt, selbst wenn wir eine Technologie haben, wird die wieder zurückgeführt.
Und wir reden nochmal darüber.
Wie können wir die verbessern oder welche anderen Möglichkeiten gibt es da noch?
Deswegen haben wir, das ist die erste Querschnittsabteilung,
die natürlich mit allen Fachabteilungen auch gemeinsam arbeitet.
Das ist die Theorieabteilung, die dafür sorgt, dass das unterfüttert ist,
dass das verstanden wird, das Phänomen verstanden wird, um es dann auch richtig einsetzen zu können.
Dann kommen danach im Prinzip die drei Fachabteilungen.
Die entwickeln tatsächlich vom optischen Tisch das, was man vielleicht in der
Grundlagenphysik verstehen würde, wirklich im optischen Tisch,
im Labor bis so ein bisschen hin zum Prototypen entwickeln, die die Technologien,
die dann spannend sind, bei denen wir Potenzial sehen.
Seien das neue Frequenzreferenzen oder neue verschränkte Quellen oder was auch
immer, da gibt es ganz viel oder neue Magnetometer, gibt es ganz viele verschiedene
Anwendungsbereiche, die wir uns da anschauen.
Und zum Schluss kommen die anderen beiden Querschnittsabteilungen da wieder
dazu, die die dann unterstützen auf dem Weg hin zur nicht wirklich Produktreife,
aber zur Prototypenreife oder zur Umsetzung in der Raumfahrt.
Das ist einmal die Integration für Mikro- und Namenssysteme,
also tatsächlich Miniaturisierung von Systemen ein ganz, ganz großer Punkt.
Wenn Sie so, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie mal in einem Labor waren,
das sind immer riesige Aufbauten, die kann dann der Postdoc XY bedienen und
wenn irgendjemand anders reinkommt, dann zerbricht das ganze Experiment und nichts tut mehr.
Das ist natürlich nichts, was wir als Technologie verkaufen können.
Das ist nichts, was irgendein Industriepartner haben möchte,
sondern die müssen tatsächlich irgendwie idealerweise in eine Schuhbox reinpassen
und man hat außen einen Stecker und auf der anderen Seite einen Anknopf und
dann funktioniert das von ganz alleine.
Auch noch, wenn man fünfmal mit dem Hammer draufhaut.
Idealerweise auch noch, wenn man fünfmal mit dem Hammer draufhaut oder wenn
man es auf eine Rakete drauf packt oder sonst irgendwas. Das Ding sollte möglichst
idealerweise, wenn man es nochmal fallen lässt, sollte es immer noch funktionieren.
Und dafür gibt es eben diese beiden verbleibenden Querschnittsabteilungen,
die zweite heißt dann Quantum Engineering, also tatsächlich die Ingenieurwissenschaft
da auch mit reinzubringen, mit einzubinden, Power Conception runterzubringen,
das System kleiner zu machen, an den Anwendungsfall anzupassen und so weiter und so weiter.
Das klingt jetzt so sehr getrennt voneinander, diese Abteilung,
und die Aufgaben, das ist es natürlich nicht. Also am Ende des Tages vermischt
sich das durchaus auch so ein bisschen.
Aber so ist der Grundgedanke des Instituts, um eben von der Idee bis hinten
raus zu einem Vorprodukt entwickeln zu können.
Ganz wichtig an der Stelle, das Produkt selber machen wir nicht mehr.
Das heißt, wir lizenzieren dann oder haben ein Patent oder machen eine Ausgründung
oder sowas und versuchen das dann auch, eine unserer Hauptaufgaben,
auch in die Industrie zu transferieren, sodass die Technologie dann eben halt
dort auch weitergetrieben werden kann.
Während wir dann wieder zurückgehen und sagen, top jetzt haben wir dieses Magnetometer,
was können wir denn machen, dass das vielleicht noch besser wird oder was können
wir denn tun, dass wir einen anderen Effekt ausnutzen können oder sowas in der Richtung.
Diese Fachabteilung haben wir jetzt kurz angesprochen, aber noch nicht benannt.
Also ich finde das ganz interessant, wie sich das aufteilt.
Quantenmetrologie, das sozusagen, das Messwesen, ja?
Das sind die mit den Frequenzreferenzen.
Also mit den besonders stabilen Frequenzen.
Genau und die haben im Moment ein ganz großes Experiment,
das nennt sich Kompassung, gemeinsam mit anderen Schwesterinstituten von uns,
wo wir versuchen, neue Frequenzreferenzen für dann den späteren Einsatz auch
im Navigationsbereich jetzt erstmal auf der ISS vorzubereiten,
um eben halt auch zu zeigen, dass wir die auch in der Raumfahrt benutzen können,
dass wir sie dort sinnvoll installieren und sinnvoll operieren können.
Ganz wichtiges Thema bei der Stelle.
Die Abteilung macht zusätzlich dann auch noch so ein bisschen den größeren Kontext
der Navigation, wo es dann auch um Inertialsensore geht.
Also da wo GNSS Signale verloren gehen, zum Beispiel im Tunnel oder irgendwie
wo schlechtes Signal ist, dass sie dann trotzdem noch sinnvoll weiter navigieren können.
Dafür entwickeln wir hier dann auch neue Systeme. Auch das wieder gemeinsam mit anderen Systemen.
Kommen wir gleich mal auf diese Projekte. Vielleicht um diese Fachabteilung
nochmal benannt zu haben.
Also neben dieser Meteorologie gibt es noch dann Quanteninformation und Kommunikation und die Nanophysik.
Korrekt. Und ja steigen wir nochmal vielleicht, da wir jetzt schon so viel darüber
geredet haben und das relativ anschaulich ist, mit diesen Navigationssystemen ein.
Also es gibt ja jetzt schon Navigationssysteme und auch Galileo hat ja im Prinzip
wie auch Nachfolgetechnologie bei GPS natürlich auch immer so mit dem Ziel,
ist ja mit dem Ziel angetreten noch genauere Ortung zu ermöglichen.
Bis hin zu so einem Submeterbereich, ich weiß gar nicht wo jetzt die Auflösung
wirklich endet, sind wir da schon im Zentimeterbereich angekommen?
Zehn Zentimeter, ich hab's nicht mehr so ganz im Sinne, also auf jeden Fall überhaupt,
also Metergenau ist ja auch schon mal was, das hat ja GPS,
einfache GPS so nicht geleistet, es gibt ja immer noch so die militärischen Varianten,
die immer noch mal ein bisschen genauer sind, die jetzt für die Allgemeinheit
nicht so ohne weiteres zugänglich sind,
aber Wovon hängt denn das ab, wie genau ein Navigationssystem ist und wie kann
jetzt so die Quantentechnologie und konkret das,
was jetzt sagen wir mal im Rahmen von Compasso gemacht hat, also was ist hier
die Idee, wie man das verbessern kann?
Was braucht es, um bessere Navigationssysteme zu schaffen?
Wir erinnern uns kurz an vorher, wo ich darüber gesprochen habe,
dass wir die vier Satelliten brauchen und ich brauche diese Zeitsignale und
ich habe so ein bisschen gesagt, ja das ist jetzt eine schlechte Abschätzung,
der sagt es ist 15 Uhr und ich sage es ist 15 Uhr eins und je genauer ich diesen
Zeitunterschied kenne,
desto genauer weiß ich auch, wo ich bin, also desto genauer weiß ich,
wie weit ist der von mir entfernt und desto genauer bekomme ich die Positionierung.
Das heißt, die Positionierung auf dem Boden hängt direkt, ist direkt proportional
oder hängt direkt ab von der Frequenzstabilität der Frequenzreferenz im Orbit.
Jetzt gibt es da zwei Punkte. Das eine ist zu sagen, die ist möglichst stabil.
Das ist das eine. Also wie genau ist der Taktgeber? Und das zweite ist,
die Genauigkeit kann auch dadurch erhöht werden, dass man eine kürzere Wellenlänge nimmt.
Das ist so, wie wenn Sie jetzt versuchen, mit einem normalen Lineal Submillimeterlängen
zu messen. Dann werden Sie einen relativ großen Fehler machen.
So ähnlich ist das hier auch. Je kürzer das Lineal, also je kürzer die Wellenlänge,
desto genauer kann die Messung passieren.
Und die Frequenzreferenzen, die wir jetzt entwickeln, sind im Optischen.
Und die optische Wellenlänge ist einfach kürzer als die Radiofrequenzwellenlänge,
sodass wir uns da auch schon durch das Konzept, durch diese neue Technologie
eine Verbesserung der Zeitreferenz erhoffen.
Aber hat man dann in dem Frequenzbereich nicht ein Problem mit Verschattung
und so weiter, weil das geht ja dann nicht mehr überall durch.
Man gibt nicht das optische Signal runter. Zumindest nicht in dieser ersten
Phase. Es gibt dann andere Konstellationen.
Das ist nicht mehr bei uns so sehr stark angesiedelt, sondern da gibt es das
Institut für Kommunikation und Navigation in München und das sogenannte Galileo-Kompetenzzentrum
auch in DLR, eine DLR-Einrichtung auch in München,
die sich dann sehr stark mit Gesamtkonstellationsideen für die nächste Generation GNSS beschäftigen.
Für mich ist hier erst mal zu sagen, diese optische Frequenzreferenz.
Verbessert das Zeitsignal, was wir bekommen können und dann gibt es später so
Ideen von Konstellationen wie zum Beispiel die Kepler Konstellation,
die dann auch optische Frequenzreferenz mit optischen Links hat und natürlich Sachen.
Also wir reden jetzt sozusagen das ganze auf Lichtbasis zu machen,
um sozusagen einen genaueren Takt für die Generierung des eigentlichen Signales zu liefern.
Man tauscht das dann, man tauscht das dann in ein Radiofrequenzsignal und schickt
dann das Radiofrequenzsignal.
Und von was für Differenzen reden wir jetzt hier,
also welche Frequenz kommt so üblicherweise, also welche konkrete Frequenz wird
jetzt von so einem Galileo Satellit, in welchem Bereich bewegt sich das und
von was für Differenzen sprechen wir jetzt hier, die ein Problem sind?
Kann man das irgendwie quantifizieren?
Da erwischen sie mich ganz, ganz kalt. Da kann ich ihnen nicht so wahnsinnig
viel helfen. Das war Episode 8, die wir vielleicht an dieser Stelle einfach
nochmal referenzieren wollen.
Ich glaube, dass die Experten ihnen da einfach viel besser weiterhelfen können,
als ich die, ich kann ein bisschen was sagen zu der Frequenzvergleichs.
Stabilität heißt ja, dass wenn die nächste Welle kommt, dass die nicht zu früh, nicht zu spät kommt.
Davon reden wir. Also dass es keine Schwankungen innerhalb dieser Frequenz gibt,
weil eine Frequenz an sich ist ja erstmal einfach erzeugt, aber ein stabiles
Signal, das ist sozusagen das Ziel.
Genau, es geht darum, dass die Wellenlänge oder die Frequenz eben immer gleich
lang ist und das ist überraschenderweise bei einem Laser als solchen zwar schon der Fall,
aber die schwanken immer noch relativ breit, das nennen wir dann die Bandbreite
und die versuchen wir hier einfach runter zu bekommen, um dann eben halt eine
höhere Genauigkeit zu bekommen.
So ein Jitter, den man da raus holen will.
Und was wird jetzt bei COMPASSO konkret getan, um da voranzukommen?
Also das ist ja ein Experiment auf der ISS, das ist da auch schon. Nee, das kommt da hin.
Das kommt da hin.
Kompasso ist ein Experiment, was genau zeigen soll, dass wir diese Experimente
oder diese Systeme, die wir brauchen, um eine Kepler-Konstellation,
um eine nächste Generation GNSS zu bauen, dass wir die verifizieren.
Und genau das, was wir vorhin hatten, mit dem wir lassen das runterfallen oder
ich werfe mit dem Hammer drauf,
kann das, überlebt das den Raketenstart, überlebt das die Operation in Orbit,
das ist nur auf der ISS, Das ist von der Strahlung her noch relativ harmlos
im Vergleich zu dem, was Galileo-Satelliten aushalten müssen,
aber kann ich das auch remote von dem Boden aus operieren?
COMPASSO kann mehr als nur die optische Frequenzreferenz. Die optische Frequenzreferenz,
die Iod-Referenz liegt bei uns, deswegen ist das für mich so ein ganz wichtiges Thema dabei,
die eben dann auch als Taktgeber für zukünftige Satelliten-Missionen geplant
wird und wo wir natürlich auch versuchen, das entsprechend umzusetzen,
aber da ist noch mehr drauf.
Da ist ein sogenannter Frequenzkam drauf, der von einem Industriepartner gebaut
wird, von Manlo Systems, der das optische Signal mit einem Radiofrequenzsignal vergleicht.
Also das macht die Umsetzung von den optischen Signalen in Radiofrequenzsignale.
Das ist nicht trivial, da gab es einen Nobelpreis für Herrn Hensch in München,
worauf basierend dann auch diese Firma gegründet wurde, soweit ich weiß.
Frequenzkamm ist eine Messmethode oder Mess...
Ist wie ein Transformator.
Ein Transformator der Wellenlänge im Prinzip.
Der vergleicht die optische, die er dann wirklich auch weit weg legt,
mit der Radiofrequenz. Ganz spannendes System, ganz lustig.
Über Frequenzkämmer könnten wir auch alleine nochmal sprechen.
Ist wirklich ein bisschen was in der komplizierteren Technologie.
Okay aber Compasso ist selbst ein, also was macht das Gerät letztlich,
was auf der ISS ist dann konkret und welche Rolle spielt Jod dabei? Genau.
COMPASSO macht verschiedene Dinge. Also das eine ist, wir zeigen,
dass das Jodsystem funktioniert, dass die Frequenzreferenz funktioniert,
dass es so funktioniert, wie wir das tun wollen.
Es übermittelt die Frequenz dann auch optisch auf den Boden.
Das heißt, wir haben auch ein optisches Terminal gemeinsam mit München,
mit den Instituten in München und mit dem Industriepartner TESAT,
wo wir dann das optische Signal mit einem Terminal auf den Boden bringen und
auch vom Boden wieder rauf, sodass wir da Signale vergleichen können.
Und das ist wirklich ganz zentral oder auch ein wichtiges Thema dabei,
macht diese Konversion in den Radiofrequenzbereich, um eben auch mit bestehenden
GNSS Systemen zusammenarbeiten zu können.
Also es wird jetzt schon so ein Modul, was an der Außenhaut der ISS installiert
wird und konkret in Kommunikation tritt mit der Erde, damit man einfach reale
Kommunikation, Frequenzkommunikation betreiben kann.
Genau.
Und das Ziel ist sozusagen, also letzten Endes ist das genauso wie die Atomuhr in Braunschweig.
Also es geht darum einfach ein sehr klares Signal zu erzeugen.
Aber die Hoffnung ist, dass man jetzt auf Basis von Jodatomen das irgendwie genauer hinbekommt.
Genau und Jod hat hier noch andere Vorteile. Also die PTB, ich weiß nicht ob
Sie da mal waren, das funktioniert auf dem Zerfall von dem Cesiumatom.
Das ist eine riesige Anlage, unsere Jodreferenz passt eben in so einen Schuhkarton rein,
sodass wir die ganzen Dinge, die die Raumfahrt mitbringen, das System muss robust
sein, das heißt es muss die ganzen Stöße und Störungen aushalten beim Start,
das muss auch die Integration auf der Außenhaut der ISS überleben.
Das System muss resilient sein, also es muss sich möglichst alleine wiederherstellen
können im Falle eines Fehlers.
Das System muss automatisiert sein.
Ich kann keine Astronauten da, die das dann mit Knöpfchen drücken und vielleicht
auch nochmal justieren und Leute solche Themen.
Das heißt, das muss auch automatisiert laufen und es muss klein sein und möglichst
wenig Stromverbrauch haben.
Das sind alles so Themen, die wir durch dieses Experiment eben auch zeigen können
oder durch diese Nutzlast zeigen können und damit eben verifizieren können,
dass die Technologien, die wir hier entwickeln, auch das tun,
was wir gerne von ihnen haben möchten.
Also das ist eine Verifikation der optischen Technologien in Orbit am Ende des Tages.
Und das Ziel ist letzten Endes damit so ein Technologiedemonstrator zu machen.
Hier mit diesem Ansatz auf Basis von Jodatomen können wir einfach nochmal viel
geilere Frequenzen erzeugen.
Habt ihr noch nie gesehen so scharfkantig. Funktioniert super.
Genau. Ich glaube vor dem Gespräch angesprochen, dass Raumfahrt immer gerne
so zehn Jahre hinterher ist. Das hat was damit zu tun, dass in der Raumfahrt
vor allen Dingen bekannte, verstandene Technologie benutzt wird.
Verständlicherweise. So ein Satellit ist sehr sehr teuer.
Wenn ich den in einen geostationären Orbit gebracht habe, komme ich da auch
nicht mehr so ohne weiteres dran. Das heißt die Technologie,
die an Bord ist, muss funktionieren.
Gut abgehangen sagt man.
Genau, gut abgehangen. Und für uns ist dieser Schritt zu COMPASSO sozusagen
ein Schritt vorwärts, um zu zeigen, dass die Technologie so funktioniert,
wie wir sie versprechen.
Und das ist für uns ein Schritt auf dem Weg hin zu Next Generation Navigation Systems.
Ist COMPASSO nach diesem Tänzer benannt?
Der Name von COMPASSO ist eine lustige Quiste.
Es ist kein Akronym, sondern es geht ja hier dabei auch darum zu zeigen,
dass wir eben diese Kepler-Konstellation bedienen möchten oder dass das so einer
der Wege ist für die COMPASSO-Technologien und auch die Galileo-Thematik ein
so ein Thema ist dafür und gleichzeitig möchten wir auch zeigen,
dass es eben in die Navigation gehört.
Kompass ist ja auch etwas, was für die Navigation nutzt.
Und Kompasso ist einer der ersten Rechenschieber, den Galileo und Kepler zusammen
verwendet haben, also es ist so ein bisschen deren Pfadfinder gewesen,
so wie jetzt unser Experiment der Pfadfinder für zukünftige Galileo-Systeme
ist oder zukünftige Kepler-Systeme.
Alright. Hat immer alles einen Hintergrund.
Es hat immer alles einen Hintergrund. Wir benennen nicht aus Versehen.
Jetzt hatten wir vorhin schon das Projekt BECAL erwähnt. Das scheint ja hier
eine wichtige Rolle zu spielen. Was hat es denn damit auf sich?
BECAL ist ein tolles Experiment. BECAL ist tatsächlich ein Akronym.
Steht für Bose-Einstand Condensate and Cold Atom Laboratory.
Was uns auch schon ganz viel über das sagt, was das Experiment kann und soll.
BKAL soll auf der ISS kalte Atome, ein sogenanntes Bose-Einstand-Kondensat,
also man kühlt und kühlt und kühlt und kühlt die Atome, bis sie nicht mehr durch
eine eigene, einzelne Wellenfunktion beschrieben wird, sondern auf einmal dieses
ganze Konglomerat an Atomen mit einer Wellenlänge beschrieben wird.
Für das erste Bose-Einstand-Kondensat gab es den Nobelpreis,
ich meine Anfang der 90er.
Also auch noch gar keine so alte Technologie, die wir da jetzt benutzen, naja 30 Jahre.
Also ein spezieller Zustand, in dem sich eine bestimmte Art von Materie,
aber nicht jegliche Art von Materie befinden kann?
Ja genau, also im Prinzip ist das ein Zustand der Materie wie das, was sie sonst so kennen.
Sie kennen sicherlich Festkörper und Flüssig und sie kennen Gas und vielleicht,
nachdem ich vorhin so lange darüber gesprochen habe, jetzt auch Plasma noch
als zusätzlichen Zustand.
Und wenn man das weiter kühlt und kühlt und kühlt und kühlt,
dann kommt man zu dem sogenannten Bose-Einstein-Kondensat, also einem Kondensationsvorgang.
Es können nicht alle Teilchen tatsächlich kondensieren, sondern nur die,
die der Bose-Einstein-Statistik folgen, sogenannte Bosonen.
Das hat was mit dem Spin zu tun.
Da gibt es den großen Unterschied zu haben zum Beispiel elektronenhalbzahligen
Spin, sagt man dazu. Das ist eine Quantenzahl, die dann bestimmt,
wie sich das Teilchen verhält.
Während zum Beispiel Protonen und Neutronen, nein das stimmt nicht,
die haben auch halbzahligen Spin.
Jetzt fällt mir kein gutes Beispiel ein, die Wechselwirkungs-Bosonen haben ganzzahligen Spin.
Das Higgs-Boson, ein typisches Boson, hat ganzzahligen Spin und danach trennt
sich das auch. Also das, was halbzahligen Spin hat, nennen wir ein Fermion,
nach Fermi und das, was ganzzahligen Spin hat, nennen wir ein Boson, nach Herrn Bose.
Und bei BKL schauen wir uns eben halt genau Bosonen an, die diese Kondensation
untergehen können. Elektronen können das, Fermionen können diese Kondensation
nicht in dieser Form unterlaufen.
Die kann man trotzdem kühlen und man kann dann ganz viel spannende Systematiken damit machen.
Aber die Kondensation geht eben vor allen Dingen mit den Bosonen.
Wie zum Beispiel das Photon.
Das Photon ist auch ein Boson. Wir benutzen in diesem Fall Rubidium-Atome und
Kalium-Atome, die dann sowohl bosonisch wie auch fermionisch vorkommen und wir benutzen da die.
Okay, also ein bestimmter Ausschnitt aus dem Teilchen-Zoo hat atomare Eigenschaften,
die es ermöglichen, dass man dieses Zeug in diesen Zustand bekommt,
den man sich quasi als weiteren Zustand neben dem, was man so kennt mit festflüssig, gasförmig etc.
Trifft, aber das findet eben nur statt, wenn es alles sehr kalt ist.
Aber wozu braucht man das?
Ja, also erstmal ist das, das ist ja jetzt genau dieser Punkt,
an dem wir jetzt an dem Überschritt sind von der Quantenmechanik hin zur Quantentechnologie.
Quantenmechanisch ist dieser Zustand alleine super spannend.
Ganz spannender Zustand, passieren ganz toll viele Sachen.
Da sitzt der Forscher und staunt.
Da sitzt der Forscher und staunt und ist ganz glücklich darüber und dann kann
man damit ganz, ganz viele tolle Sachen machen. Das erste, was man damit machen
kann, ist tatsächlich, also wir haben jetzt zwei Dinge.
Das eine ist, diese Atome haben Masse. Das heißt, ich habe so eine Wolke,
die hat Masse. Die folgt einer Beschleunigung. Feld zum Beispiel im Erdgravitationsfeld.
Das ist jetzt der eine Punkt. Der zweite Punkt, der ist fast noch wichtiger.
Ich habe über diese Wolke eine Wellenfunktion drüber liegen.
Ein anderes System, was eine Wellenfunktion hat, die das sehr toll beschreibt, ist ein Laser.
Da habe ich einfach diese eine Wellenlänge, die beschreibt, der Laser ist super,
der ist total stabil, vielleicht habe ich ihn auch noch stabilisiert,
ich bin total glücklich.
Dann mache ich damit Interferometrie, um Dinge zu vermessen.
Abstände oder Bewegungen oder sonst irgendwas. Aber immer das Problem,
dass der Laser selber nicht Masse behaftet, ist der Laserstrahl als solcher.
Das heißt ich kann nur die Bewegung dadurch messen, dass sich irgendwie ein
Abstand verändert oder dass irgendwie eine Testmasse sich verändert.
So wie man zum Beispiel Gravitationswellen misst, indem man Laser wohin schickt
mit dem Spiegel wieder zurück und wenn sich da zwischen der Raum expandiert,
dann ändert sich die Frequenz des Lasers und daraus kann man das dann ablesen.
Nicht die Frequenz, sondern nur das Interferogramm am Ende.
Achso ja okay, also die beiden, also man schickt ja zwei im 90 Grad Winkel und
guckt ob die sozusagen danach auch wieder überlagern und wenn nicht dann hat
sich halt der Raum bewegt, gekrümmt oder?
Genau, dann ist die Distanz kürzer geworden und auf einmal ist da wo die beiden
Wellenberge war, es ist jetzt vielleicht ein Wellenberg und ein Wellental und
das löst sich auf und auf einmal, das sieht man ganz schön, dann wandert das
Interferenzmuster am Ende so ein bisschen.
Das ist genau das, was man macht. Also ein super schönes Beispiel dafür, absolut.
LIGO und auch LISA. LIGO ist der auf der Erde, LISA ist der im All.
Der irgendwann mal im All sein soll, ja genau. Kommt noch.
Kommt noch. Total spannendes Experiment. Und wir haben jetzt den Vorteil,
dass wir diese Wellenfunktion haben, aber das System ist in sich massenbehaftet.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt, wenn ich mit den...
Also die Interferometrie mit den Atomen machen, nicht mehr an den Atomen.
Also ich habe keinen, es ist nicht so, dass ich mit einem Laser reingehe und
den zurückgehe und ich gucke dann in der Laserinterferenz nach,
sondern ich benutze die Atome, um damit Interferenz zu machen.
So ähnlich wie vorher mit den Fullerenen am Doppelspalt.
Nur dass wir jetzt die Spalten durch Laser erzeugen, es wird sehr, sehr kompliziert dann.
Kann ich damit Interferenz machen und kann eben mit diesen Atomen jetzt Systeme probieren.
Insbesondere Beschleunigung. Und eines der ersten Experimente,
was man damit versucht hat zu machen, ist die Äquivalenz des freien Falls zu untersuchen.
Ganz spannendes System. Wenn Sie jetzt eine Feder und eine Bleikugel fallen
lassen, dann behaupte ich, dass die gleich schnell fallen. Und dann sagen Sie,
nein, das tun Sie nicht. Und dann sage ich ihnen, ja dann haben sie noch ein Luftproblem.
Und dann nehmen wir die Luft raus und auf einmal sehen wir, dass die gleichzeitig fallen.
Für interessierte Zuhörer, es gibt da ein tolles Video von der NASA,
man sieht nicht so richtig viel drauf, aber ich glaube Neil Armstrong hat das
tatsächlich auf dem Mond gemacht.
Da hat er einen Hammer und eine Feder oder sowas auf den Mond fallen lassen
und man sieht auf diesem Video auch wie das gleichzeitig fällt und das ist eine spannende Frage.
Ist tatsächlich dieses Äquivalenzprinzip, dieses Einstein'sche Äquivalenzprinzip,
Ist das valide bis überall oder finden wir da eine Verletzung?
Das ist eine totale Grundlagenthematik, aber die kann man mit diesen kalten
Atomen eben untersuchen.
Das wurde gemacht oder wird jetzt geplant auf einer sogenannten Höhenforschungsrakete,
wo man ein Bose-Einstein-Kondensat auf eine Rakete packt, schickt das hoch und
es kommt wieder runter. Sechs Minuten Schwerelosigkeit und kann in dieser Zeit
eben Experimente machen.
Um das zu tun, muss man zwei verschiedene Massen miteinander vergleichen.
Ich muss also zwei verschiedene schwere Objekte haben und gucken,
wie fallen die im gravitativen Potenzial.
Bei uns machen wir das mit überraschenderweise Rubidium und Kalium.
Man vergleicht das Fallen, die Beschleunigung in dem Gravitationsfeld durch
sehr genaue Interferenz an diesen Testteilchen und kann damit dann zum Beispiel
das Äquivalenzprinzip vermessen.
Jetzt habe ich schon gesagt, ich kann damit also Beschleunigung messen,
wie zum Beispiel die Erdgravitation.
Super, dann kann ich das bestimmt auch für andere Dinge einsetzen.
Also hier wäre die Quantenmechanik als Sensor für andere Fundamentalphysik gewesen
und jetzt ist die Frage, kann ich diesen Sensor, den ich für die fundamentale
Physik eingesetzt habe, nicht auch für alles andere nutzen?
Gibt es nicht vielleicht noch andere Anwendungsgebiete, in denen ich das benutzen kann?
Vermessung der Erdschwere, gab es ja schon einige Systeme, Goethe aus Europa
und ich glaube die Amerikaner hatten auch noch zwei, drei. Grace. Grace, genau.
Und das ist ja schon ganz gut vermessen. Aber man will ja immer genauer sein.
Wie, also das heißt, ich stelle mir das jetzt so ein bisschen vor,
es gibt da halt so einen Kühlschrank, da ist irgendwie dieses Einstein-Bosel-Kondensat da drin,
sozusagen so eine, wie soll ich es nennen, Also so ein Gemisch in diesem Zauberzustand,
in dem sich alles irgendwie gleichförmig verhält, wie kann man dem denn jetzt
sozusagen diesen Messwert entlocken?
Also wie fällt das an? Also die Gravitation wirkt dann halt auf diese Masse ein.
Und wie kriege ich dann diesen Wert heraus? Woran kann ich feststellen,
aha da rupft jetzt was hier an meinem Kondensat?
Also zunächst mal machen wir hier keine Zauberzustände.
Das funktioniert alles, das ist alles tatsächlich… Bevor ich jetzt irgendeinen
Vergleich mit Eis und Gas und so weiter mache, es ist ja ein anderer Zustand,
was weiß ich, ich hab's ja noch nicht gesehen, vielleicht sieht das ja ganz irre aus.
Ja, das ist Ei… ja, genau. Das kondensiert… ich nutze immer gerne die Jugendlichen,
die sich hinten im Bus alle auf den gleichen Sitzplatz setzen.
Also ich hab einfach gelernt, alles was jenseits unseres bisherigen Verstehens
ist, ist das was man Magie nennt. Also von daher ist das für mich jetzt als
Zauberzustand ganz wertfrei.
Genau, genau deswegen ist es für mich keine. Natürlich brauchen wir da so ein
bisschen Geschick und geschultes Personal, da steckt ganz viel Knowhow drin, es ist aber keine Magie.
Wir verstehen wie die Systeme funktionieren.
Aber wie entlockt man dem jetzt sozusagen diesem Zeug einen Messwert?
Bei dem Laser verstehe ich das aber.
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen tricky für mich zu erklären ohne dass ich dabei
Bilder malen darf. Das ist die Kunst.
Prinzip ist wichtig.
Normalerweise fange ich jetzt an zu malen, weil dann erklärt das sich so ein
bisschen einfacher. Also, was man macht, ist...
Wenn Sie sich jetzt vorstellen, Sie haben diese Atomwolke und jetzt nutzen wir
einen ersten Laserstrahl und teilen die in zwei Anteile.
Das ist im Prinzip genauso wie das,
was bei LIGO passiert. Man nimmt den Laserstrahl und teilt ihn in zwei.
Dann mache ich eine Rückreflexion mit einem zweiten Laserstrahl,
sodass die wieder aufeinander zufallen und in einem dritten teile ich wieder jeden von denen,
sodass ich am Ende dann zwei Massen bekomme, in denen sich die beiden dann überlagern,
in denen ich einen Anteil von dem unteren Ast habe, der mit dem oberen Ast überlagert
und einen Anteil, in dem sich der obere mit dem unteren überlagert.
Sodass ich am Ende zwei Auslesewolken habe am Ende des Tages.
Also man geht richtig konkret mit dem Laser durch dieses Kondensat durch.
Genau. Nur dass der Laser hier wirkt wie bei dem Laser-Experiment die Spiegel und die Strahlteile.
Das heißt der Laser ist zunächst ein Strahlteiler, dann ein Spiegel und wieder ein Strahlteiler.
Und solange wir keine Gravitation haben, bewegen die sich eben auf diesem Pfad
und ich kombiniere sie hinten und ich sehe keine Veränderung in dem Endresultat.
Und jetzt ganz ähnlich wie bei Ligo und Lisa, wenn sich das jetzt im Gravitationspotential
bewegt, dann fallen die nach unten.
Das heißt, ich verändere die Länge dieser Wege und damit auch verändere ich
auch das Auslesesignal und kann dann aus dem Auslesesignal die Beschleunigung
ablesen, die ich vermessen habe.
Und jetzt haben Sie gerade die beiden Experimente angesprochen,
GOCE und GRACE, die funktionieren ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
GOCE vermisst eine Gradiometrie, also die Veränderung des Gravitationsgradienten
entlang des Gravitationsvektors.
Das kann ich also hier genauso machen. Ich messe also an zwei übereinander geordneten
Positionen entlang des Gravitationsvektors,
die Gravitation mit dem Atometerferometer und bekomme einen Gravitationsgradiometer,
eine Goethe-artige Konstellation mit einem Satelliten, die das Erdschwerfeld vermisst.
Und bei GRACE ist die Situation ein bisschen anders. Bei GRACE hat man zwei
oder mehr, wir lassen mal diese ganzen anderen Konstellationen,
wo dann irgendwie mit drei vorgeschlagen wurde und dann so zueinander verkippt
und so, das lassen wir mal alles raus.
Gehen wir mal von der einfachen GRACE Konfiguration aus. Da habe ich zwei Satelliten,
die fliegen hintereinander her.
Und wenn jetzt unten drunter eine höhere Masse ist, zum Beispiel im Berg,
dann wird die Beschleunigung durch diese höhere Masse größer.
Das heißt der erste wird von dem zweiten wegbeschleunigt und die Entfernung
zwischen den beiden wird größer.
Dann fliegt der drüber, wird gebremst und dann kommt der zweite hin und wird
beschleunigt, dann wird der Abstand kleiner. Wenn der zweite drüber geflogen
ist, wird der auch gebremst und wir haben wieder den Originalabstand zwischen den beiden.
Damit messe ich das Gravitationspotential. Ich mache einfach eine Entfernungsmessung
zwischen diesen beiden Satelliten.
Ganz einfach.
Ganz einfach. Also schon das Tracking ist super simpel. Verstehe gar nicht. Total einfach.
Dabei ist es jetzt ganz wichtig, dass ich unterscheiden kann,
ist diese Abstandsmessung, die ich mache, ist das tatsächlich ein gravitatives
Signal oder liegt das daran, dass diese Satelliten gewackelt haben?
Das heißt hierbei kann man Atominterferometer einsetzen, um die Beschleunigung
des Satelliten zu vermessen und das Signal dann eben zu trennen von dem Gravitationssignal.
Wichtig an der Stelle, BKL machen wir hier auch,
aber der Hauptanteil von BKL,
also das Physics-Package liegt bei einem Schwesterinstitut in Hannover,
bei dem Institut für Satellitengeodäsie und Inertialsensorik und wir haben ganz,
ganz viele nationale Partner da drin, die verschiedene Systeme bauen,
das Lasersystem, die Elektronik.
In die Infrastruktur und dann auch noch ganz wichtig, BKL ist eine Kollaboration
mit der NASA, die uns dann auf die ISS bringt und die ISS zur Verfügung stellt.
Warum sage ich das alles?
Weil diese Erdbeobachtungsmissionen danach, diese GOCHA-artigen,
also die Gradiometrie und die Gravimetrie,
die GRACE-artigen Experimente, das ist alles ganz viel Expertise,
die auch in Hannover liegt, bei dem Institut für Satellitengeodäsie und Inertialsensorik,
die dann auch tatsächlich Abteilungen haben, die diese Laser-Link-Systematik im Griff haben.
Offensichtlich ist es so einfach, dass wir eine ganze Abteilung dafür brauchen,
die die Atominterferometrie da drin im Griff haben,
die dann die Modellierung des Ergebnisses,
also die Rückführung dieser Abstandsmessung auf ein Gravitationssignal,
auf eine tatsächliche Gravitationsfeldkarte zurückführen, lauter solche Sachen.
Also da passiert ganz viel in verschiedenen Dingen.
Ich muss ja nochmal fragen, was die Erwartung ist und wie viel genauer man so
eine Messung dann mit diesem Kondensat durchführen kann als mit diesen anderen Methoden.
Also eines der Hauptdinge und da gibt es eine Studie,
die viel Kritik auch erfahren hat, weil die relativ einfache Modelle reingesteckt haben,
ist, dass man damit die, also zum einen natürlich macht man die Sensitivität
besser, aber das was man eben auch wegbekommt ist die Drift.
Das ist das, was wir vorher auch bei der Navigation hatten, die Ihnen die Navigation
im Auto kaputt macht, wenn Sie in den Tunnel reinfahren.
Dann reibt das an irgendwas und dann geht das irgendwie mit der Zeit daneben.
Und so ähnlich ist das hier auch.
Die Systeme, die wir im Moment verwenden, die haben alle irgendwie eine Reibung an irgendetwas.
Also ich muss irgendwie immer, ja den Beschleunigungssensor,
den ich drin habe, muss ich immer irgendwo festhalten, damit er mir sagen kann,
wie stark das System sich bewegt.
Diese Drift haben die Atominterferometer nicht, sodass ich immer einen absoluten
Vergleich bekomme über die verschiedenen Orbits und damit auch eine bessere
Übersicht über Streifen, die nebeneinander passieren.
Also wenn der Satellit 2 benachbarte Orbits überfliegt,
dann bekommt man da im Klassischen ein sogenanntes Striping und auch dieses
Striping wird man reduzieren können mithilfe von dieser … Weil einfach quasi
die Messfehler geringer werden und man nicht mehr so unterschiedliche,
grundlegende Daten hat.
Beim zweiten Mal rüber, es nähert sich alles vom Messergebnis mehr aneinander
an. Genau. Okay, nachvollziehbar.
Jetzt diese, das Beispiel ist ja jetzt schon ein paar mal gefallen und das ist
ja auch sagen wir mal etwas, was man so aus der normalen Lebenswelt eben auch
kennt, so diese Navigation in Tunneln.
Ich hatte da schon, als das so losging mit diesen Handys und mit den Ordnungen und so,
kennt ja jeder, man fährt da so in den Tunnel rein und dann auf einmal so,
ja ich seh keinen Satelliten mehr und WLAN gibt's ja auch nicht,
was mir weiterhelfen kann und der Tunnelbetreiber hat jetzt auch sonst hier
keine Beacons installiert, die sagen würden wo man jetzt gerade ist und der
Tunnel ist so ein bisschen länger und windet sich jetzt durch die Alpen.
Klar, dann funktioniert natürlich eine Satellitennavigation nicht mehr,
aber die Telefone haben ja einen Beschleunigungssensor da drin und so rein theoretisch,
rein theoretisch müsste man ja jetzt durch kontinuierliches Auslesen dieses
Beschleunigungssensors nachvollziehen
können, wie das Auto sich denn nun durch diesen Tunnel bewegt.
Aber man hört es schon, sie schütteln mit dem Kopf. Leider nein.
Ganz so einfach ist es dann doch nicht.
Also das funktioniert für eine gewisse Zeit, der Beschleunigungssensor,
insbesondere der im Auto, der weiß ja auch wann ich lenke und so,
aber da ist eben immer diese mechanische Reibung mit drin, die eine Drift erzeugt.
Aber in meinem Telefon noch nicht.
Auch in dem System in ihrem Telefon erzeugt der eine Reibung,
der muss ja irgendwie festgehalten werden, die Masse muss ja irgendwie ausgelesen
werden, die ist ja nicht schwerelos da drin. Dafür, dafür.
Dafür liegt das jetzt auch schon zu lange auf dem Tisch, als dass ich glaube,
dass das schwerelos da drin ist.
Ja okay, also sozusagen die Schwerkraft zieht ja permanent an diesem Sensor.
Also wenn man mit dem Computer so einen ganz normalen Beschleunigungssensor
ausliest von einem Telefon, was auf dem Tisch liegt, dann liefert das ja die
ganze Zeit eine Beschleunigung, weil ja die Erdbeschleunigung die ganze Zeit drauf wirkt.
Das ist richtig, das ist aber nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist,
dass der Sensor an irgendwas fest sein muss.
Damit der eben halt irgendein Signal gibt, muss der ja irgendwie sich bewegen können.
Ich muss diese Bewegung auslesen und ich muss den irgendwo halten.
Es gibt die elektrostatischen, aber auch die elektrostatischen müssen,
halten das System fest. Der hält das elektrostatisch in dieser Position und
dann wackelt das da drin. Das heißt aber ich habe immer noch eine Reibung.
Also ich habe immer noch irgendwie eine rückstellende Kraft,
die das System wieder in den Ursprungszustand zurückbringt und das sorgt für die Drift.
Und die Drift sorgt dafür, dass nach relativ kurzer Zeit, tatsächlich auch im
Tunnel, nach relativ kurzer Zeit die Genauigkeit der Position stark runtergeht.
Bei ihrem Handy haben sie da noch den Vorteil, dass sie, solange sie noch Signal
haben, also noch Mobilfunksignal, kann das auch noch helfen.
Das macht dann eine Triangulation über die verbundenen Masten.
Das kann helfen, aber nehmen wir das mal weg, dann haben Sie einfach nur diesen
Inertialsensor und der kommt sehr, sehr schnell an seine Grenzen und braucht
sehr schnell wieder ein GNSS-Signal, um zu sagen, ach so, da bin ich.
Das sehen Sie auch daran, wenn Sie Ihr Handy aufmachen und Sie haben diesen
kleinen blauen Punkt in der Mitte und dann ist da dieser große blaue Kreis außenrum,
der sagt, das ist die Genauigkeit Ihrer aktuellen Position. Das hat genau was damit zu tun.
Das wird immer, also wenn wir jetzt kein GNSS hätten und kein Telekom und sie
würden damit loslaufen, dann würde dieser blaue Kreis sehr schnell immer immer
größer werden, weil er immer ungenauer weiß, wo sie sind.
Der Kreis der Unsicherheit.
Der Kreis der Unsicherheit. Den können wir hier mit Inertialsensorik basierend
auf Quantentechnologien eben durch diese Driftfreiheit in dem Sensor,
können wir den reduzieren.
Und diese Driftfreiheit, die leitet sich woraus genau ab?
Bezieht sich das jetzt auch wieder auf dieses Bose-Einstein-Kondensat oder reden
wir jetzt noch von einer anderen Anwendung?
Man kann das auch auf der Erde machen, aber bleiben wir mal bei dem Bose-Einstein-Kondensat
und bleiben wir mal bei den GRACE-Satelliten, bei denen ich ja im Prinzip die
Inertialsensorik genau dafür benutze.
Dann habe ich eben den Vorteil, dass dieses System frei mit dem Satelliten um die Erde fällt.
Das heißt, ich muss das nicht festhalten und damit befähigt sich das in einem
sehr, sehr guten Vakuum.
10 hoch minus 10, 10 hoch minus 11 Millibar. Da ist wirklich wenig Reibung.
Da ist noch eine Rechtsreibung, was damit was zu tun hat, dass wir nicht so
richtig gutes Vakuum da reinbekommen. Aber da ist nicht mehr viel Reibung,
sodass es wirklich keine Drift gibt.
Ohne Reibung geht das nicht viel. Theoretisch. Da ist natürlich die reale Welt
immer noch so ein bisschen so eine Sache.
Aber es ist so eine einheitliche Masse,
die sozusagen in einem klar definierten Zustand ist, wo jedes Teil sozusagen
derselben Gleichung gehorcht in diesem Zustand und deswegen sich gut messen lässt.
Das Ensemble gehorcht der Wellenfunktion, mit der wir es beschreiben können.
Und das bewegt sich eben ohne Reibung. Und ohne Reibung geht der Fehler,
den man durch Drift macht, verloren.
Jetzt fragen sich ja schon alle so, okay Raumfahrt und jetzt reden wir über Tunnel und so,
aber es gibt ja auch Orte, wo man so hinfährt, wo es ja noch kein GPS gibt,
wie zum Beispiel auf dem Mond oder so oder auf dem Mars, da könnte man sowas
dann gegebenenfalls vielleicht auch zur Navigation benutzen.
Das ist schön, dass Sie das ansprechen.
Ich bin aufgefordert, am Montag die Antworten auf die Peer Review,
also der wissenschaftliche Prozess funktioniert.
Ich schreibe ein Paper, einen Aufsatz, gebe den an ein Journal,
die geben den an Wissenschaftler, die überprüfen das und schicken mir Fragen
zurück. Das ist das sogenannte Peer Review, also die Überprüfung durch andere Wissenschaftler.
Zu einer Frage, die Mission heißt Marquis, bei der wir das Gravitationsfeld
des Mars mit einer ganz ähnlichen Konstellation wie die Grace-Konstellation untersuchen wollen.
Und natürlich, ja, Navigation auf dem Mond, Navigation auf dem Mars,
aber das ist alles so ein bisschen zu kurz, also es gibt auch noch ganz viel
mehr Quantentechnologie.
Also es gibt im Moment an Bord von JUICE ist ein Quantenmagnetometer.
Das heißt, die können auch da, zieht wieder das Argument der Driftfreiheit,
dieses Quantenmagnetometer muss nicht kalibriert sein und dient als Kalibrationseinheit
für die tatsächlichen Messmagnetometer, um die Genauigkeit zu erhöhen,
um diesen Abgleich eben regelmäßig zu machen, sodass es in der Exploration,
Untertitel der Amara.org-Community,
Auch bereits ganz viele Quantentechnologien gibt, auch über die Navigation hinaus,
sondern auch eben Untersuchung vom Planeten.
Magnetometrie wird viel eingesetzt, um so unter der Oberfläche Ozeane und sowas zu finden.
Gerade bei den Monden der Gasgiganten, wie es so schön heißt.
Genau, Jules ist ja die Jupiter Icy Moons Explorer Mission.
Habe ich übrigens auch eine Sendung zugemacht, Raumzeit 95, als ich neulich
bei der ESA in Madrid war und das startet ja auch bald, also wir haben heute,
nehmen wir gerade auf, am 24.
März und am 13. April soll es dann endlich mal losgehen mit dieser Mission,
wo ich gerade dabei bin. Gotcha habe ich natürlich auch eine Sendung zu gemacht.
Raumzeit 40, da kann man sich nochmal die Vermessung des Gravitationsfelds der
Erde anhören. Hervorragend. Genug geplagt.
Alles gut, aber was Sie jetzt schon sehen ist, dass wir … Aber diese Navigation,
aber das ist ja sozusagen, also okay, also Vermessung, aber es gibt ja sozusagen
auch so Navigationsprobleme.
Also ich erinnere mich bei der Rosetta Mission gab es glaube ich das Problem,
also das ist ja dann sozusagen Navigation im All ist ja dann,
also diese Fernmission funktioniert ja auf Basis von Star Trekern,
da gibt es halt keine GPS Satelliten, aber da gibt es halt viele Sterne und
man kennt das Sternbild ja mittlerweile ziemlich gut.
Das heißt in dem Moment wo man eben mit dem Star Trekker auf die anderen Sterne schaut,
dann gibt es mittlerweile die Technik die halt relativ schnell sagt,
okay alles klar, sieht so und so aus, Pattern Matching und so weiter,
wir sind hier und das kann ja auch die Position verhältnismäßig gut berechnen.
Aber ich glaube, als dann Rosetta in der Koma des Kometen gelandet ist,
also im Nebel sozusagen, da war es dann mit dem Star Trekker nicht mehr so.
Korrekt. Korrekt. Das ist sicherlich auch ein Anwendungsgebiet.
Ist vielleicht nicht ganz so massentauglich, aber absolut.
Das gilt auch nicht nur für solche Missionen, die auf Satelliten landen wollen,
sondern auch beispielsweise für den Mars, auf dem Staub ein echtes Problem ist,
der dann sich eben auch auf dem Star Trekker ablagern kann und dann verliere
ich damit auch die Genauigkeit.
Also von daher, da gibt es ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz viele Anwendungen der Navigation
in der Exploration oder auf der Erde oder ja, wo auch immer.
Bei denen wir mit Quantentechnologien helfen können. Und wo sie das gerade angesprochen
haben, sie haben jetzt irgendwie drei oder vier von ihren alten Podcasts,
konnten wir irgendwie im Beitrag oder im Beitrag jetzt hier ansprechen.
Ist ganz klar, was man dabei sieht, ist, dass die Quantentechnologien eben wirklich
in ganz vielen verschiedenen Bereichen eingreifen können und mit Sensorik bei
ganz vielen verschiedenen Themen auch angreifen können und Beiträge einfach leisten können.
Wenn man sich jetzt mal so vorstellt, nur mal so als Gedankenexperiment und ich weiß,
mit der Quantifizierung ist
das gerade bei den Quanten immer so eine Sache, aber nehmen wir mal an,
man hätte jetzt sozusagen einen driftfreien Inertialsensor jetzt mit,
Hat ja so seinen Bose Einstein Kondensat und
so hält da ein Laser rein und weiß so okay alles klar das macht jetzt das und
das und jetzt würde ich irgendwie eine Rakete starten und würde dann ab einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt parallel zu einem Star Trekker quasi nur über diesen Beschleunigungssensor,
der letzten Endes ist, versuchen meine Position zu berechnen.
Könnte man davon ausgehen, dass das dann ähnlich genau,
genauso genau, vielleicht sogar noch genauer ist als andere Methoden,
also dass man wirklich auch über einen längeren Zeitraum im Raumflug dann wirklich
die Position so mithalten könnte, rechnen könnte?
Also es gibt natürlich so ein paar Realitätsabstriche, die man machen muss.
Was? Wirklich?
Ja, ist furchtbar. Aber prinzipiell ist das genau die Idee.
Also es ist tatsächlich, da man eben halt die Driftfreiheit gewinnt,
gibt es keinen Grund, warum dieser Sensor daneben gehen sollte.
Man muss da ein bisschen über Repetitionsraten reden und über Implementierung
und über Sensitivität des Sensors, der dann mit der Größe koppelt.
Also je kleiner das System, desto weniger sensitiv. ganz typisches Problem.
Wie gesagt, das sind so äußere Probleme, so Vorrandbedingungsprobleme,
über die man sich dann kümmern muss.
Gedanken machen muss, die dann sehr anwendungsspezifisch sind,
aber prinzipiell gibt es keinen Grund, warum das nicht einen Star Trekker ablösen
könnte, außer den Swap Budgets, also Size, Weight und Power.
Da ist der Star Trekker sicherlich überlegen, wenn ich also eine Mission habe,
in der ich wirklich weiß, ich fliege, ich weiß nicht, zum Uranus oder zu Neptun
oder sowas und das ist wirklich ganz kritisch und ich weiß auch,
ich habe keinen Staub in der Nähe.
Da ist wahrscheinlich ein Quantensensor, also ein Quanteninertialsensor einfach ein Tacken too much.
Auf so einer Mission allerdings ein Quantenmagnetometer mitzufliegen ist sicherlich sinnvoll.
Jetzt gibt's noch so einen Bereich der ganzen Quantentechnologie,
der ist mir auch selber so ein bisschen, also mir ist hier sowieso das meiste wirklich ein Rätsel,
aber das ist nochmal so ein spezielles Rätsel und das ist dieses Ding mit dieser Verschränkung,
vielleicht können wir da nochmal kurz drauf kommen und das spielt ja dann auch
eine große Rolle in so Technologie-Bereichen wie Verschlüsselung oder auch der,
ja, Kommunikation, beschäftigt man sich hier damit oder was hat es da generell mit auf sich?
Also hab ich einen schlechten Job gemacht, wenn das immer noch alles so magisch wirkt.
Aber Verschränkung haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht geredet, weil das ist ja irgendwie
so dieses merkwürdige Eigenschaft, dass Dinge an mehreren Orten sein können.
Das ist so ähnlich, aber das ist, ach ja, genau.
Dröseln wir das doch mal kurz auf.
Also zunächst mal beschäftigen wir uns damit. Sie haben vorhin die verschiedenen
Abteilungen des Instituts vorgelesen. Da gibt es eine, die nennt sich Quantenkommunikation
und Information, Information und Kommunikation, andersrum.
Wir sind sehr überrascht, wenn wir jetzt feststellen, dass diese Abteilung sich
vor allen Dingen mit Verschränkungen beschäftigt.
Es gibt auch andere Themen bei der Verschränkung, wieder in Hannover,
die da auch versuchen dann zum Beispiel die Atominterferometrie damit zu verbessern
und so, aber lassen wir das mal außen vor. Was bedeutet Verschränkung?
Verschränkung ist ein ganz typisches quantenmechanisches Phänomen,
was wieder an sich darauf zurückgeht, dass wir vieles über Wahrscheinlichkeiten
beschreiben und eben nicht über Tatsachen.
Stellen Sie sich vor, ich habe eine Box und die Farbe der Box ist definiert
durch die Dinge, die ich reinlege.
Wenn ich eine rote und eine blaue Kugel reinlege, ist die Box lila.
Jetzt mache ich die Box zu. Die Box ist lila. Und die Information,
die ich jetzt von außen habe, ist, dass die Gesamtfarbe ist lila.
Und das Wichtige dabei ist, ich habe die da nicht wirklich reingelegt,
sondern die sind da einfach drin. Und das, was ich weiß, ist,
dass eine der Kugeln rot sein muss und die andere muss blau sein,
wenn das von außen lila ist.
Und dass es wirklich zwei Kugeln sind.
Und dass es wirklich zwei Kugeln sind. Und ich weiß, dass es zwei Kugeln sind.
Wie wir da hinkommen erkläre ich gleich noch. Aber ich weiß,
dass es zwei Kugeln sind und ich weiß, dass eine von den Kugeln rot sein muss
und die andere muss blau sein, wenn das System von außen lila ist.
Was ich nicht weiß und wenn ich sage was ich nicht weiß, dann heißt das,
was quantenmechanisch unbestimmt ist, ist die Farbe der tatsächlichen Kugeln.
Also die Kugel 1 hat 50% Wahrscheinlichkeit rot zu sein und 50% Wahrscheinlichkeit
blau zu sein. Und genauso hat die Kugel 2 50% Wahrscheinlichkeit blau zu sein
und 50% Wahrscheinlichkeit rot zu sein.
Also man weiß, eine ist rot, eine ist blau, aber man weiß nicht welche.
Ja es geht sogar weiter. Die sind nicht rot oder blau. Ich weiß nicht nur nicht welche.
Die haben beide 50% Wahrscheinlichkeit in den beiden Zuständen zu sein.
Also die eine hat 50% Wahrscheinlichkeit rot oder blau zu sein,
die andere hat 50% Wahrscheinlichkeit rot oder blau zu sein.
Solange ich nicht reinschaue, habe ich keine Chance.
Das ist im Prinzip diese Idee von Schrödingers Katze, die ja dann noch ein bisschen weiter nachgeht.
Ob die Katze tot ist oder nicht.
Ja das ist ja dann ob das Element zerfallen ist oder nicht eigentlich.
Dass dann den Hammer auslöst, der das Gift und dadurch die Katze stirbt.
Das ist ja das Experiment.
Konnte sich keiner merken.
Lieber die Katze tot oder lebendig. Richtig. Und das ist hier ganz wichtig.
Das heißt allgemein bedeutet Verschränkung. Ich kenne den Gesamtzustand,
aber ich kenne die Einzelkonstituenten nicht. Ich kenne den Zustand der Einzelkonstituenten nicht.
Und in der Verschlüsselung macht man das so, dass man vorne ein Photon reinschickt
und dann nimmt man ein Kristall.
Dieser Kristall produziert mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit horizontal
polarisierte Photonen, Sie kennen das vielleicht aus dem Kino,
wenn Sie mal in so ein IMAX gegangen sind, das 3D Ding.
Da bekommt man so eine Brille und das eine Glas ist vertikal polarisiert und
das andere horizontal polarisiert.
Was da drin ist, ist im Prinzip nur so eine Plastikfolie, die Streifen in horizontaler
oder in vertikaler Richtung hat und da nur entsprechendes Licht durchlässt.
Und wenn ich die jetzt übereinander lege und 90 Grad aufeinander drehe,
dann kommt da nichts mehr durch. Das können Sie mal ausprobieren,
wenn Sie das nächste Mal so ein 3D-Kino anschauen, dann kommt da auf einmal kein Licht mehr durch.
Das nennen wir, damit ist das eines horizontal polarisiert, wenn ich das durch
das vertikal polarisierte Licht durchgehen lasse, dann kommt eben kein Licht mehr durch.
Das ist im Prinzip die Idee von Polarisation. Das gleiche machen wir hier.
Wir schicken ein unpolarisiertes Photon rein.
Und hinten kommen zwei raus und wir wissen, dass es insgesamt unpolarisiert sein muss.
Und das heißt, die beiden haben jeweils 50 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit,
vertikal oder horizontal polarisiert zu sein.
Das ist ein Gesamtzustand. Jetzt kann ich an zwei Stellen messen.
Ich nehme diese beiden Photon, messe sie irgendwann und stelle einen horizontalen
Polarisationsfilter rein und dann messe ich dahinter, ob ich das Photon gemessen habe oder nicht.
Wenn ich es messe, war es horizontal polarisiert, wenn es nicht messe,
war es vertikal polarisiert. Und gleichzeitig muss das auf der anderen Seite,
wenn ich es hier horizontal messe, muss es dort vertikal sein und dann war es rum.
Jetzt kann ich das messen und ich erzähle es mir nicht und dann kann ich damit
im Prinzip einen Schlüssel generieren.
Weil ich ja immer weiß, was der andere gemessen haben muss.
Weil man von der einen Messung auf die andere schließen kann.
Weil ich von der einen Messung auf die andere schließen kann.
Wichtig ist dabei, dass dieser Zustand existiert über die beiden Photonen in
diesem Fall oder über die beiden Kugeln vom Anfang.
Der existiert, bis ich die Schachtel aufmache, bis ich messe.
Und es gibt jetzt viele, viele Experimente, die versucht haben herauszufinden,
ob dieser sogenannte verschränkte Zustand, ob der irgendwann eine Grenze hat.
Also wie weit kann ich diese beiden Photonen voneinander entfernen und auf einmal
kollabiert dieser Zustand zu früh, bevor ich ihn messe. Gibt es irgendwie eine
Entfernung, über die das funktioniert?
Das ist lustigerweise eine andere Gruppe in Wien. Wien ist ein ganz heißes Pflaster
für Quantenphysik und auch für Quantentechnologien.
Die haben sich das angeschaut. Die armen Doktoranden mussten nach Teneriffa, glaube ich.
Die armen Doktoranden. Die haben mir wirklich leid getan. Weil da die Luft schön
dünn ist oder schön gleichmäßig und man dann zwischen den Inseln auch viel Platz
hat, um diese Experimente zu durchzuführen.
Hat das dann zwischen den Inseln gemacht. Dann bekannt geworden ist das Mithios
Experiment von den Chinesen gemeinsam mit den Österreichern am Ende des Tages.
Die haben den Satelliten gebaut und haben dieses verschränkte Photon vom Satelliten
auf den Boden geschickt.
Einen nach Österreich und einen, ich meine nach Gengzhou in China.
Und haben sich angeschaut, ob das eben auch funktioniert und konnten damit nachweisen,
dass diese Verschränkung über 7400 Kilometer...
Wie haben die denn ein Photon von Österreich nach Japan geschickt?
Nach China.
Die haben im Prinzip auf dem Satelliten die beiden Photonen entscheucht.
Achso von einem Satelliten.
Der METIUS Satelliten.
Ja, ja ich dachte schon. Ich hätte das nicht mitbekommen mit der Erdkrümmung.
Genau. Okay. Und die haben damit gezeigt, dass das eben...
Über sehr sehr sehr sehr große Entfernungen funktioniert, sodass wir diesen
Effekt jetzt eben auch ausnutzen können.
Das eine ist die Grundlagenforschung daran, die sogenannten Bell-Tests,
benannt nach Herrn Bell, der so der erste war, der ein Experiment vorgeschlagen
hat, um diese Verschränkung zu testen.
Die Verschränkung, die hat Einstein spooky interaction at a distance genannt,
also geisterhafte Fernwechselwirkung, weil das ja dann, das ist ja das, was es erscheint.
Ich messe hier und da passiert auf einmal was und ich kann das irgendwie über
mehrere tausend Kilometer tun und bekomme immer noch, erhalte immer noch diesen Zustand und diese.
Ich frage mich gerade, wie kann man denn überhaupt über tausende Kilometer diese
Photonen durch die Gegend schicken und dann noch genau dieses eine Photon messen?
Aber woher weiß man denn, dass das genau das war?
Das ist schon eine Herausforderung, zumal wir auch, da gehen ja auch Verlustraten dann mit ein.
Also es kommt auch nicht jedes Photon an, was ich aussende und so.
Und ich muss auch einzelne Photonen messen. Das ist nicht so trivial,
aber es ist möglich. Es ist wirklich möglich.
Auf jeden Fall war Einstein derjenige, der damals gesagt hat,
das glaubt er nicht, da kommt das, Gott würfelt nicht her.
Und hat an sogenannte verborgene Variablen geglaubt oder postuliert,
glauben ist vielleicht in dem Kontext nicht das richtige Verb,
sondern hat dann verborgene Variablen postuliert,
die eben für uns unsichtbar, aber diese Zustände definieren,
sodass die zwar von außen so aussehen, als wären die Zustände nicht definiert
auf den Teilchen, aber dass sie eine verborgene Variable haben,
an der das tatsächlich definiert wurde. Und das ist dann mit Bell-Tests.
Möglichst Long Range Bell Test, also über feite Distanzen testet man eben genau
diese Hidden Variables, diese verborgenen Variablen und bisher müssen wir feststellen,
die Quantenmechanik ist gültig.
Aber welche konkreten Auswirkungen auf Technologie hat das jetzt?
Wie kann man das zur Anwendung bringen? Wie wird das schon zur Anwendung gebracht
und was ist hier so die Vorstellung davon, was sich daraus an Technologie ableiten lässt?
Ja also die ganz klare Situation dabei ist Schlüssel zu erzeugen.
Ich kann zwischen den beiden Empfängern einen quantensicheren Schlüssel erzeugen.
Der hat verschiedene Vorteile. Zunächst mal ist der echt zufällig,
wenn ich die Quantenmechanik drunter lege.
Wir reden von Schlüsseln für kryptographische Verfahren und da ist ja immer
dieser Schlüsselaustausch,
ist ja im Prinzip so das eigentliche Problem, weil wenn beide Seiten miteinander
kommunizieren wollen über eine Verschlüsselung, dann läuft diese Verschlüsselung
ja eben über einen Schlüssel, hence the name.
Das heißt man hat quasi ein Parameter für diese ganzen mathematischen Berechnungen,
der dann auf beiden Seiten in der Lage versetzt, sowohl Informationen zu ver-
als auch wieder zu entschlüsseln.
Aber man muss ja dazu darüber einen Austausch machen und wenn man diesen Austausch
sozusagen über diese Methodik quasi schon weltumspannend erzeugen kann,
dann gibt es sozusagen keinen abhörbaren Bereich dazwischen.
Ja, also die große Herausforderung dabei ist ja, dass ich ihnen meinen Schlüssel geben muss, irgendwie.
Ich muss den Schlüssel irgendwie austauschen. Wenn das abgehört wird,
dann habe ich den Schlüssel in der Hand von dem Dritten, der dann alle meine
Nachrichten überprüfen kann. Der die Sachen selber entschlüsseln kann.
Das heißt zum einen den Austausch von dem Schlüssel sicher zu machen und zum
anderen einen sicheren Schlüssel zu generieren.
Sie kennen unterschiedliche Schlüsselsicherheiten auch aus dem privaten Bereich.
Meine WhatsApp-Verschlüsselung, wenn sie denn überhaupt existiert,
ist sicherlich eher weniger sicher. Die, die meine Bank benutzt,
um Daten zu übermitteln, ist hoffentlich etwas besser.
Und das hat ein bisschen was damit zu tun, welcher Schlüssel da zugrunde liegt,
wie dieser Schlüssel generiert wird und wie lang er ist.
Bisher sind wir auch da stark darauf angewiesen, dass diese Schlüssel,
die idealerweise zufällig sind,
Die werden von dem Computer erzeugt. Die sind also nur so zufällig,
wie der klassische Computer zufällig ist.
Und das ist nicht besonders zufällig, sodass die Quantenmechanik uns hier zwei
Vorteile bringen kann. Das eine ist die tatsächliche Zufälligkeit des Schlüssels
und auf der anderen Seite die Nichtabhörbarkeit der Schlüsselerzeugung.
Sodass eben halt wirklich diese beiden Parteien den Schlüssel haben am Ende des Tages und ich nicht,
oder ich diesen Schlüssel nicht mehr klassisch übermitteln muss,
sondern ich habe diesen Schlüssel bei den beiden Parteien erzeugt,
die dann ihre Nachrichten verschlüsseln und dem anderen schicken und der andere
kann das entschlüsseln.
Und das heißt jetzt schon Technologie, wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen,
Sinn dieses Instituts ist Grundlagenforschung aufzugreifen und sozusagen wirklich
mindestens Modelle zu entwerfen, vielleicht Patentenverfahren etc.
Oder eben auch konkrete technologische Ansätze, um das in irgendeiner Form real
anwendbar zu machen. Ist man da in diesem Bereich schon so weit oder bewegt
sich das nicht noch sehr im theoretischen Grundlagen?
Also theoretisch bewegt sich das alles nicht mehr.
Die Systeme, wir wissen, dass es geht, wir haben es experimentell getestet,
wir haben die Experimente zur Verfügung.
Das bewegt sich im Moment noch alles auf einem relativ geringen Level,
was Industrialisierung angeht.
Die Systeme werden tatsächlich auf Satelliten betrieben, wir wissen, wie es geht.
Und wir forschen natürlich auch immer noch an der Verbesserung von den Quellen
und von den Detektionssystemen, das ist im Moment alles noch sehr balky und
sehr groß, aber prinzipiell ist das durchaus schon angewendet.
Und wenn wir uns JUICE anschauen, ich weiß, das ist jetzt nicht mehr die Verschränkung,
aber ich würde sagen, wenn ich ein System auf einer der großen ESA-Missionen,
auf einer der großen Raumfahrtmissionen mit draufbringe, dann ist das kein...
Kein Experimentieren mehr an dem System, sondern tatsächlich dann ist das ein
Sensorsystem, den ich nutze, um neue Dinge zu erforschen. Also von daher ist da durchaus auch was da.
Jetzt haben wir lange über die Verschränkung gesprochen. Die Verschränkung ist
auch das, was unter dem Quantencomputing drunter liegt, sodass wir uns auch
hier in die Anwendung im Moment bewegen.
Also das heißt auch, das Quantencomputing ist ja durchaus etwas,
was auch schon genutzt wird und auch von industriellen Partnern schon genutzt wird.
Oder auch von Industrie bereits hergestellt wird.
Haben wir denn jetzt schon alles tangiert, mit dem sich dieses Institut so auseinandersetzt?
So im Groben schon. Ich kann jetzt natürlich noch irgendwie drei Stunden weiter
reden, welche anderen Anwendungen es noch gibt.
Wichtig ist mir noch anzumerken, dass wir diese Systeme natürlich auch für verschiedene
Anwendungsbereiche einsetzen wollen und ein wichtiger Anwendungsbereich dabei
ist für mich auch der Klimaschutz.
Also die großen Herausforderungen unserer Zeit damit anzugehen und auch im Klimaschutz
dann zu schauen, wie wir Quantentechnologien einsetzen können.
Na das eine ist die ganze Erdbeobachtungsschiene, die wir jetzt ja auch schon besprochen haben.
Eben anzuschauen wie der Planet sich verändert dadurch, dass wir da sind.
Wie die Goldkappen abschmelzen und Leute solche Dinge. Andere Dinge sind auch
über verbesserte Navigationssystemen, Routen zu verbessern und Autos oder insgesamt
Fahrzeuge schneller von der Straße zu bringen.
Von A nach B und dann nicht irgendwie noch drei Schleifen zu fahren,
bevor man dann da hinkommt.
Solche Themen fallen da auch mit runter. Also ganz viel von dem,
was wir heute schon besprochen haben.
Die Überwachung des Erdmagnetfeldes, das sich ja auch dauernd wandelt und dauernd verändert,
dass es nicht so sehr in diesem Climate-Change-Thema mit drin ist,
aber sicherlich auch ein Thema, was die Umweltbeobachtung, die Erdbeobachtung,
die Beeinflussung des Klimas angeht.
Ohne Menschen gemacht zu sein. Genau, lauter solche Themen. Wie können wir Quantentechnologien
eben als Querschnittsthema hier auch einbringen, um bei Klimaforschung zu helfen,
um bessere Klimamodelle zu entwickeln, um mehr Daten zu generieren.
Wie entwickelt sich denn so das Interesse an dem Thema Jenseits,
also sozusagen in der Außenperspektive eingenommen,
weil ich meine es gibt ja viele Bereiche, wo so an allem möglichen interessanten
Zeug geforscht wird und wenn man mal reinfragt, sagst du, um wofür kann man
das benutzen, also Weltrevolution, es ändert alles und so weiter,
also kann ja jeder sagen, sag ich mal so, ne?
Ist sozusagen Quantentechnologie jetzt mehr auf dem Radar als noch zuletzt,
vorhin kurz gesagt, eine gute Zeit, um jetzt mit diesem Institut anzufangen?
Warum ist das so? Hat sich irgendwas an der Wahrnehmung geändert oder gibt es
die technologischen Durchbrüche oder ist alles andere gerade so am Ende,
dass man da nicht mehr weiterkommt?
Was macht das sozusagen aus?
Nee, ich glaube es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir gerade mit diesen großen Missionen,
die wir jetzt ja auch angesprochen haben, mit Beka und Compasso,
wirklich dahin kommen, dass wir die Technologie entwickeln können.
Und wir sind nicht die einzigen.
Also das ist ein weltweiter Trend, der viel Technologieentwicklung im Moment
vorantreibt und wir sehen das in ganz vielen Bereichen,
dass das mehr und mehr auch auf Interesse stößt und die Systeme eben auch genau
wegen der Vorteile, die sie bieten, mehr und mehr eingesetzt werden.
Ich meine natürlich gehe ich davon aus, dass wir die Welt retten.
Das ist mein, das ließ ich glaube ich auch.
Ich glaube, ich wäre ein schlechter kommissarischer Institutsleiter,
wenn ich das nicht glauben würde. Von daher, ja.
Super, dann bleibt mir erstmal nichts weiteres als Danke zu sagen für die Ausführung.
Die Technologie war sehr interessant
und hat neue Einblicke geliefert und interessante Perspektiven,
wie sich ja auch so die Raumfahrt dort verändern kann,
weil gerade so im Bereich Kommunikation und auch so Fernkommunikation,
also Missionen die weit raus gehen, Uranus und Neptun klangen an.
Ich glaube es wird tatsächlich drüber nachgedacht bei der NASA dann doch vielleicht
mal wirklich dort auch mal hinzufliegen und demnächst mal eine Mission zu formulieren.
Ich fände das ja mal ganz gut, weil da ist ja seit Voyager nicht viel passiert.
Und die ganzen Missionen haben immer das Problem, viele Daten werden eingesammelt,
die müssen auch irgendwie alle wieder nach Hause telefonieren und da gibt es
noch einiges zu verbessern.
Genau, auf jeden Fall.
Und Navigation im Nebel und im Tunnel natürlich ganz wichtig.
Navigation, Erdbeobachtung, Inertialsensorik, Kommunikation,
Magnetfeldsensorik, Computing, ist nicht so stark angeklungen heute,
aber ja. Es gibt ganz, ganz viele Bereiche, in denen wir unterstützen können.
Vielen herzlichen Dank.
Ja, ich hab zu danken und vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit.
Bald geht's wieder weiter, tschüss und bis bald!